hi I'm Kristi Larson I'm the teacher who
founded freako camp five years ago and I
am thrilled today to bring you this
video it's very different from what
we've been publishing on freako camps
YouTube channel for the past five years
we've been publishing in-depth tutorials
and full courses on Python Java
JavaScript Kotlin a whole lot of
different topics and we've also been
covering important libraries like pi
torch PI game tensorflow
things like that so a little push hey
Quinn you ready all right I'm gonna get
back here with less money so we are
going to be in this episode interviewing
some of the most interesting people in
open source that would be of course
Adams - Kovach and Jared Santo from the
legendary changelog podcast if you
haven't heard the changelog it is the
preeminent podcast on open source
software and pretty much every major
open-source maintainer has been on there
at some point Dan Abramov DHH you who to
cats and then of course a whole lot of
main hinders you haven't heard of they
have hundreds of episodes and this is
their ten-year anniversary so I drove
down to Houston Texas hung out with them
in the studio and we recorded five hours
of interviews okay I interviewed them
for like two and a half three hours then
they turn around and interviewed me for
like an hour and a half all of that is
going to be on this video I've added
timestamps below so you can jump
wherever you need to go in the video and
just a quick heads up this is not a
visually stunning video this is three
people sitting in a studio talking in on
microphones I would encourage you to
consider doing dishes maybe going to the
gym maybe driving to work doing other
things while you watch this video
because just sitting there staring at
the three of us sit in our chairs for
five hours
would not be the best use of your time
so listen to this and the background
while you do other things that don't use
your brain fully so you can still pay
attention to the interview and enjoy I
think you're gonna learn a lot and I
learned a lot about both Adam and Jerrod
they had never done an interview like
this where they talked about their
background Adam was in the military
Jared was like a recipient of several
scholarships and he has some interesting
stories behind that and that's how he
was able to go to school and then just
how they got into the software
development what kind of freelance
projects they've been doing the story
behind the change like all this stuff is
so fascinating and so again enjoy the
video and remember like after this we're
gonna go straight back to publishing
full-length courses this is just a
one-time video so but I think you'll
really enjoy it and have fun happy
coding everybody
hey welcome to the free code camp
podcast we have a very special podcast
today we are interviewing the founder of
the changelog and his sidekick so I'm
gonna introduce them properly in a
moment but I just want to welcome you
this is a special episode of the free
code camp podcast because we're
technically on hiatus for the rest of
the year while we handle a whole lot of
other burning fires but I have been a
huge fan of the changelog ever since I
started my developer journey back in the
early 20 teens and this show has been a
huge window into the world of open
source development for me and I've
learned so much from so many of the
Masters of open source development by
listening to the changelog and today I
am thrilled to flip it and ask a whole
lot of questions to the creators of the
show and celebrate their 10 year
anniversary how many podcasts you know
of that have not been on on the 10 years
not matter or any no all right so first
Adams - Kovach the founder of the
changelog and the host for the past 10
years and Jared Santo who has stepped in
and been a huge force in the changelog
over the past few years and we're gonna
learn a whole lot about him let's go
first Adam I just want to learn a little
bit about you what was your early life
like Adam uh you want to go back to like
the beginning beginning like early life
I mean like eight five what whether
there were any really formative
experiences in your childhood go for it
but yeah I would say for me probably the
one thing that wouldn't seem obvious is
I grew up or like from a town that
people either go to jail become
alcoholics you know just not a lot of
hope and I came from a place where I
would say that to be where I'm at today
if people see me that I met and went to
school with years and years ago just
don't believe it
you know my dad died when I was really
young so it was a big part of my life to
have a father figure missing in my life
my mom was amazing she she raised me and
my brother single mom you know and I
love her she's she since passed away in
2008 but she was always my encourage or
always my believer in me and and quite
honestly she's the reason why I'm at
where I'm at because I guess ages ago
when blogging was cool right back in
like 2003 talking floor all right oh
yeah what it became when was the the era
of blowing the biosphere right yeah it's
the blogosphere I had a blog right and
it was I didn't live right next to my
mom anymore I had moved and was enough I
was about five hours away so I had to
have a blog to you know keep up with
family it was where we posted our family
pictures and just did whatever and I
shared my thoughts and I got really into
web design through WordPress and the
theme kubrick if anybody remembers
kubrick I do I work over that was an
entry point for me that's how I learned
CSS by like looking at that CSS and
Billy what is margin what is padding all
that stuff and so I got really curious
about web design and you know just all
that stuff and got really into it and
then I got really busy at work and just
sort of like didn't have enough time
because it was just a hobby for me at
the time and my mom's like you know
you're not doing this anymore why not
you know this and that and I'm like
that's not time for it's no big deal
whatever she's like but you're really
good at it and like she's like you're
really good at it you shouldn't stop you
shouldn't quit you're really good at
this you should to find a way to do this
more and you know it was literally that
moment when she said that that I sort of
internalized that as like oh okay mom
says I should do it I should do it and
literally if she didn't say that and I
know how silly blogging would have been
at that that time it was not even a cool
blog it was just yeah my family blow it
was like nobody should ever read it not
interesting thoughts at all but she's
like you should keep doing this and
that's that's probably one of the most
formative things for me I would say to
get me to here
there's a couple other things of course
- but that's specifically around Web
Design web development
like pursuing it deeper was that moment
hmm yes so you touched on the fact that
you were working and you were working in
another field and just pursuing software
development as a passion let's back up a
little bit to you know high school
you're in this town where generally
people don't go on to bright features
how did you break out that sheer luck
share luck God's will I would just say
gosh man I just you know I look back on
this times so I was the person that
didn't have any money for college and my
friends my money my close friends had
some sort of plan because their parents
were fortunate enough to have money the
bank and make that plan for me I didn't
have that plan I didn't even have great
grades in high school was terrible not
because I wasn't smart but because it
just didn't have anybody really a sign
for my mom and a couple others like
really helping me to apply things and
when I graduated high school I barely
graduated it was terrible
like I missed so many days of school the
last year in my high school year like I
just didn't want to be there anymore I
wanted to move on to whatever was next
and when I left high school this is like
going super deep but when I left high
school I I kind of told myself you know
I need to make a plan and so the cool
thing to say would be I'm taking a year
off you know prior to going to college
well I just have any money to go I
didn't have a plan like how am I gonna
get there and so I spent the next year
after high school sort of like making
some sort of plan I worked at this place
called Reese Brothers where they did
telemarketing hey I wasn't telemarketer
once at one point in my life I actually
may have called you at one point to ask
you about AT&T long-distance it was
probably like 10 cents or whatever and I
can give you a great deal if you bought
today hey that's how that worked
but yeah it's a telemarketer got done
with that and then I became a pizza guy
I started to like toss pizzas and flip
them and spin them there was a local
mama pop stuff local mom-and-pop pizza
joint
called I forget but it was amazing
amazing they had this thing called a red
top it's the amazing pizza and then my
roommate at the time that moved out of
my home and went and got an apartment
the buddy of mine and all that good
stuff well he was in the National Guard
and I come from a family that has you
know all of the all of the men in my
family have all been in the military my
dad my grandfather's my brother my
uncles so it wasn't like this legacy
thing but I was like hmm I got to do
something maybe I'll make enough money
to buy a car I was really motivated by
money in the car and like some sort of
like money for college and so the SDL I
built was an option then and sounds like
well alright I'll go in the military so
I went into the military full-time in
1998 and so I was in the Army for three
and a half years they had this special
program where you can go into it was
training plus three years or something
like that and so I went in for training
which was about six to eight months and
then three years of service so it's
around three and a half almost four
years not quite four years so typically
the term of service is four years so
that's why I'm making a big deal about
it cuz anybody listening will be like I
thought four years was the minimum well
I kind of got off a little bit there by
shaving a few months off but went to
Bosnia you know did all sorts of cool
stuff in the in the army went over in
Europe gosh that's a lot of fun so I
mean the military Jared knows I've told
Jared this story at least but the
military for me was there was a moment
when I was in this thing called AIT
advanced individual training everything
in the military is in acronyms so
there's always like something you know
you got art you know UCMJ that's the the
the rules set us into the the government
for lack of better terms the the laws
what am I getting at so when I was in
the ite the drill sergeant like I was
just I was even though I went in the
military I was trying to like do
something I didn't really apply myself
to be the best soldier I was still sort
of like figuring it out and I wasn't
doing a great job I was late not
prepared not the best at physical
fitness you know so I was like the the
lower echelon
soldier and so one day I'm staying in
the in the third the third line of a
formation and the drill sergeant says Mr
Gove yak front center your first squad
leader now and so that means that you're
now the leader of the first squad and
there's like usually like you know three
or four squads so like three different
lines so if you think of a formation
it's the rows are squads and so if
you're on the if you're on the the if
you're facing the formation on the far
left side that's the first person and
that's the person that's in charge of
that squad so I got I got basically made
under the person who is in charge of the
unit
I was the second-in-command for lack of
a better terms and I didn't do anything
to deserve it or earn it he just gave it
to me and and like from that day on I
was like I'm a leader now I have to be a
leader how do I be a leader how do I
lead how do I what's it look like what
does it leader look like how do they
talk how they walk how do they act and
it sort of sort of reshaped my formation
of what it meant to lead I started to
you know press my uniform shine my boots
you know they call it dress right dress
in the military be very you know you
know all the angles are squared and what
not so I just I just I guess I was given
an opportunity to lead which is why I'm
a huge advocate for you know just
helping somebody that doesn't even think
they deserve it or know how to do it
give him a chance you know encourage
them into a leadership position and I
was not the best I probably feel a lot
and that doesn't matter though because
because where I'm at today as a man as a
dad as a father as a leader of any sort
is because of some of those moments we
must have seen a lot in you if he gave
you that responsibility so it was
possible that I don't think he did
honestly I don't think he did I don't
think I deserved it at all he wasn't
like oh he looks good let's get him up
here I think he was just like Rando and
I think I was telling Jared the story of
the day like he's like would you what
you say would you would you thank him
today or something like that yeah well
we were talking about people who
influenced their lives and the question
is should you go back to that person
because you don't you don't appreciate
it then
I mean sometimes you do but especially
as a young person we just don't
appreciate what we have that the
opportunity is given to us and the
question is well now that we have we
look back and I said we're talking about
a teacher of mine shout out to mr.
Kasner
in high school there he is a guy who
like I was like wow I didn't realize it
but you're he was a good teacher and he
impressed things upon me and the
question was well would you go back to
that person if you could and just thank
them because now you have that
appreciation and now that's what I was
asking you and I would and I was like
well you know what I did today I was
googling drill sergeant Hillard you know
the person's name that that did this and
I was like what's what's really
interesting as somebody in that position
he probably has no idea he changed my
life and I mean like this these things
happen out there that we don't get that
feedback loop like as software
developers and people who you know deal
with teams and flows and frameworks and
systems we crave that feedback loop and
it's a it's a built-in mechanism into
the human brain to desire and need that
feedback loop right to have relationship
is a key humanistic feedback loop find a
human in solitary confinement whether
they're in the you know in the caves or
in you know in prison or something like
that you find somebody super alone
you're gonna find somebody seriously
dealing with some mental issues because
of that solitary that because of that
silliness and yeah I don't think he has
any any idea that he influenced my life
so well which is crazy to me yeah the
feedback loop it's very loose in the
real world it's really I mean who knows
were you able to find him on Google so
many guys is mad [ __ ] kinda got scared
for a second because I did find an
article from the base I was at that was
tragic and I started reading through it
and thank God his name wasn't in it it
was something else you know sad about
the situation but I was like gosh Here I
am looking for this person and something
bad happened to them or whatever you
know you find something obituaries you
know and it's kind of terrible too cuz
like if you're out there and you're
listening to this you're thinking
there's somebody who influenced my life
try to thank them if you can because I
mean the last thing I would want is to
find that person's obituary and it'd be
too late
you know if I could find them somehow
some way I would be like thank you so
much for sharing leadership with a crap
soldier like me because wow I choose my
life it's a great reminder I'm gonna
have to put that on my to-do list
because I've got a lot of people myself
who have steered me in the direction a
lot of teachers a lot of employers and
managers yeah so you get back from the
army and you did your three years and in
your your education before that did you
end up going to school or what did you
do from there that's funny so that's
actually the next part that got me to
where I'm at closer to videos I would
say at least so here specifically
geographically in Texas so for a little
while there I lived in Canada and that's
a really long story and I don't like
going into that but I went from the
military to Florida because a good
friend of mine that I grew up and went
to high school this is one of the people
who had a plan had parents who with
money and and they sent into college to
school and so instead of going to school
I went into the military this person my
good buddy
Donald Kilgore you know Don yeah we work
with decayed quite a bit he he went to
film school in Orlando Florida in a
place called Full Sail really well known
for audio-visual directing film all that
good stuff and so I left the military
with like this s GI Bill thinking I'm
gonna go to Florida and I'm gonna go to
film school or I'm gonna go to audio
school so I'd wanted to do either
directing of films or get into like
audio stuff around films I loved it I
didn't know how to do it but I liked the
idea of it which is so ironic of what I
do now at least one component my job and
yeah I never what school I never went I
never ended up making it there which is
kind of an interesting story if you want
to go there I can I can happen to like
the next I would say if we had like
facet my skill set one of my biggest
skill sets is sales and just
relationships and partnerships I love
that kind of stuff
and I'd mentioned Rhys brothers and
doing telemarketing what always been I'd
always like to help people and so I
think when when you say well sales is
really just trying to help people solve
their problems it's not about getting
Jarrod to buy something he didn't want
to buy with money he won't have you know
it's it's about he has a problem I can
help solve that problem that sales to me
and that's what we did we solve people's
problems in a lot of ways and so I kind
of a long story I'll make it really
short I had a friend who was trying to
be a DJ and we were at a club early in
the day kind of like 7 o'clock times he
born in the club it's not the time you
want to be a DJ and so we were there I
see him talking to this guy at the bar I
see him go back into his thing
and I go over and introduce myself
because I'm I'm like if you're a friend
of my friends or a friend of mine kind
of a kind of person I said went over and
introduced myself as a hate I saw you
thought my buddy down my name is Adam
etc or whatever and long story short
this person's name was Sean Hughes
another person that I would love to see
again and thank because that day he was
I was at a crossroads of like what I was
doing which wasn't basically nothing I
had no really ambition at the time I was
like I'm really hating what I'm doing
now thing about getting the car sales
the car sales right I love selling hey
people need cars I can write help you
solve your problem by getting a great
car whatever but car sells is generally
not the most fun sales job it's got a
lot of just a lot of achiness to it so
yeah you know it doesn't have a great a
great reputation for being great job you
can make a lot of money but it may not
be the best job for you and so long
story short I meet Sean he's like don't
get in the car sales I've been in the
car sales it's terrible don't do that I
tell you what come in on Monday this is
Friday coming on Monday to my office
he's selling a great young man got a
great head on your shoulders I got
something I'm working on at a company
called Muzak I'd love to interview you
for this thing we have going on so
that's another like huge moment my life
where I went from like no direction to
erection I go in on Monday meet with
Sean it's a great office it's a legit
job or you got a dress nice right and
you get a computer like you know to be
like I'm not talking to a POS which is a
point-of-sale system or you know which
is nothing wrong with that it was just
the next direction for me because at the
time I was I was a server I was serving
you know waiting tables doing that kind
of stuff in Orlando making good money
because lots of hospitality around that
area but yeah this guy man hired me into
this position it was an LAPD program
called leads appointments deals
proposals so more acronyms not the
military this time but leads
appointments deals proposals that's what
it was all about I was basically inside
sales for Account Executives
and I learned the ropes of this business
if you haven't heard of music if you've
been in to say old Navy or Banana
Republic or any sort of like upscale
retail environment they put the sound
systems in they put the music in and
that's what I learned how to do like
this sort of like a soundtrack to evoke
an emotion right I started getting into
user experience this whole aspect of
design and stuff like that
music had a really good brand design I
always thought it was elevators or they
thought began okay so it began in like
the early 1920s gotcha as a combination
of music and Kodak because the person
who had founded music it was a whole
different era but he loved the he loved
he loved music and he loved Kodak
company name origin story yeah you could
do worse you could do worse and so you
know I got into sales there I started
making good money and yeah that's that's
I never made it to school though so that
the interesting to answer sort of a
long-winded version of like did you go
to school the answer is no but I found a
really awesome job that helped me learn
all sorts of skillsets that I literally
used today to help build our business
yeah and I guess to some extent like
they used to say going to the military
was like an alternative to go into
school cuz you learned a lot of the same
yeah right you learn how to
struck how to operate and structure and
everything and by that time you'd
already traveled around the world and
done a lot of things to expand your
horizons anyway yeah I'd seen I was used
to traveling I was used to being a
vagabond for lack of better terms you
know just pack a bag go somewhere or
take a few things only very add but I've
slept in some really weird places and
I've also showered and not showered in
some really weird places
so I've actually the longest stretch
I've gone for not showering is about
three and a half weeks
what wow we were on a field problem and
you were lucky it was just like a
certain kind of field problem where we
had to it was simulating a real world in
battle environment kind of thing and we
were learning because we're going to
Boston so we had a train so when you go
in the military you just don't know how
to be a soldier and how to do these
things and go overseas and do different
stuff you have to train to do these
things so we went to training to learn
how to you know go overseas and kind of
simulate that now I shower over there
which is awesome but during this day
they call them field problems during
this field problem yeah I didn't shower
I mean a wash rag to myself maybe a
little bit like a legit in the shower
shower I might be pushing a little bit
at least two weeks maybe three weeks
yeah and I don't know if I could do it
like it was tough I've been knocking
myself over every time I lifted my arm
everybody smelled wraps around like it's
bad for a while but eventually you just
kind of get used to it it goes back to
normal yeah it's kind of like yeah after
a while it just sort of like normalizes
I will say that when the feel problem is
over and we all got back to the barracks
the first few in that immediately went
and showered came out from their shower
and then everybody else is still coming
in you're like oh my gosh you guys smell
so bad like it was it was pretty bad at
that point you can smell the difference
and the line for that shower must have
been like tightly packed everybody's
like anticipating the hot water yeah
yeah this I may forget that I don't
really know I'm sure you lost it out
there's always a lines like londe brush
her teeth
even as yeah yeah so how did you
transition from doing sales from music
and and you said doing some
some kind of in the direction of user
experience design yeah choosing music
and trying to evoke specific emotions
and communicate certain things how did
you explain the processes transitioning
from that to getting more and more
passionate about tech and ultimately
doing what you're doing now yeah it's
it's interesting that one of the things
that made me realize I was more geeky
than I'd ever thought I was because I
was never like I guess just that when I
grew up computers weren't around
everywhere to sort of like easily
stumble into or more easily get into you
know and so you almost had to really try
and so at the first time I had a phone
was at this job they gave me a cell
phone it was next to that's how old how
long ago it was though there's a next
telephone a night phone a next telephone
is crazy and the very first time I had
my own laptop was at this job
the first the first time I like really
used a computer for anything that was
not like online chats or just whatever
dinking around was at this job so I'd
kind of gotten into there's a I don't
know still around but it was called act
an act database it was a good maybe you
know this you've seen a Jared but as a
databasing system for like a basic CRM
and that I started that sinker with that
I was never really good at it but I
started taking some classes around it
and just realized that I had this sort
of inkling into like a geek or what I
considered a geek at that time
geeky things you know and music had a
really interesting brand a really clean
design a really a real focus on how they
say things and it's funny one thing we
actually have that's a behind the scenes
repo on github it's it's a repo we
called one voice so that Jared and I can
sort of like say the same things and
sort of define the same things around
our business to say when we talked to
somebody around a partnership or a sales
opportunity or you know our guest guide
various things were in this so that
Jared and I can have you know and begin
to develop one voice for whomever sort
of leads commands and interacts with you
know these levels of our business and so
that's something that they had they
actually had this entire book called one
voice and I was like that's really
interesting how much you think about
the emotion that you want to invoke as a
part of your brand you know who you say
you are really matter to music and they
could have just been they had some
really good branding people right and
people believed in it but hey I drank
the kool-aid man I was all in it
so that's kind of what got me into it
but I'd actually I mentioned at some
point I moved to Canada I moved to
Canada as part of my job and they had an
affiliate there and I was working in
Canada and long story short this is when
George Bush was president the Americans
did not have a great reputation abroad
whether it was Canada Europe wherever
else at least from from my perspective
because people would not buy from me
because I was an American right so I'd
like was an amazing salesperson killing
it like I think at age 21 when I was
working at Muzak in the United States I
was making like 80 90 kg R in sales like
I was just doing it for like full-time
sales for like less than a year almost
barely two years if that so I was really
killing it I was like top five or
beginning the contract from using for
you yeah and then going there and it's
nothing against Canadians but I was I
felt really I don't know how to describe
it just felt I guess it felt really sad
that that these people would not buy for
me because of where I'm from them
because I have an American accent and
I'm not Canadian and don't say eh I love
Canadians they're amazing and I was like
okay I just can't make ends meet so long
story short I went there to work for
this company there and I just couldn't
cut it and so I knew somebody who who
ran this IT business which is really
where my story of technology and like
true web and software and stuff became a
thing and like networking because this
business was called IT weapons they were
IT weapons you get it right okay it was
pretty cool it was pretty cool they did
Citrix they do VMware they did like
watch watch guard like so they did
hardware and software they would do
large-scale Citrix implementations and
this is when it was all about
thin-client fat what's the other server
yeah like that you did all of it on
servers so citrus was like you know you
had a thin client that was you know kind
of stupid no it was just a terminal to
write your server and so everything was
server based and it was just an
interesting area this is around 2003
2004 or 2005 timeframe so that's kind of
the error then learn about servers what
they were all that good stuff and it's
it's just pretty crazy to think like
this job at IT weapon's started to open
up doors into into software how where
technology and at one point I didn't
even know what a server was like I hear
it I I hear people say server but like
what's a server so so ultimately of
course you went on to found one of the
most important podcasts about software
am i right and yet you were working in
sales yeah there must have been a pretty
big transition there yeah just give us
some broad strokes about how how you
went about getting more technical this
was kind of interesting too because I
kind of stumbled into it right like when
I was working about two weapons I was
learning more I was starting to take
over the website for IT weapons and I
was starting to deploy it and stuff like
that which was like basically just
dragging and dropping an FTP it was
really you know it was those days kind
of thing it was a self built PHP kind of
just a rendering kind of situation so it
was really interesting that that's like
how much things have changed I started
getting more and more responsibility
there around that kind of stuff and sort
of like defining where the brand went
how we spoke we would have in office
kind of like conferences for lack of
better terms where I would organize them
I would like get the people there to
speak from Citrix from WatchGuard from
you know from VMware or whatever and I
would coordinate people I would
coordinate the clients and just kind of
like started layering on all these
different things of like bizdev design
sales you know all that kind of stuff
and then a buddy of mine which
ultimately came here to Texas I was in
Canada a buddy of mine sort of reaching
out to me about like I don't know what
why he asked me these things but like
he's like hey
got this issue with this webpage I'm
making can you help me and I started to
solve his problems and he is like hey
can you just build these things for me
I've got some clients and like so next
thing you know I started to just like
moonlight in freelance in web design and
develop and solid design it I would
develop it I would ship it I would
support it and I would help you know to
some degree even land the deals you know
so it's sort of like full full spectrum
of like identify people to work with
understand what their problems that was
this asana fit it and then build it and
make it and ship it and support it and
after a while he was like do you just
want to because he's a good buddy of
mine I grew up with him I was kind of
telling you that some of my friends had
plans he was the one that had a plane
went to school and he was the one that
went the full sail his name's Donnell
Kilgore love Donald he's like you just
want to like become a partner my
business and help me do this and so we
did sort of land some really big clients
I think probably the biggest deal we
landed was like 20 or 30 thousand
dollars and I was like for a website
that was a big deal it was an RV
dealership here in Texas called the Mont
Ron they're really well known around
here they have Chrysler Jeep for
whatever and they have an RV place and
so we built out and this is actually
leading into rails too because this is
like 2005 David had recently just said
whoops and we were all watching you know
I'm saying right right David I'm all
right that's right David on my video I
in five minutes yeah and so we had we
had built this version of of de mantra
and we didn't really like how it was
functionality and so that's when rails
was really cool I started getting into
that more I reached out to some people
and kind of put together a team I was on
the front end and they were building up
the backend we built out this really
awesome site in rails and I think I just
kind of stumbled into it because I
wasn't trying to be even though I know I
said my mom said I'm really good at it I
was really thinking I would be a web
developer I kind of like just was doing
it was into like biz des if I really
like to create and develop relationships
and I just see that as like one more way
to do it because one I could do it well
no one else was really doing it I had an
opportunity I can cultivate clients I
can do
a lot of these interesting things and
the door just opened up yeah and I
imagine a lot of the job was
communicating well yeah the clients and
understanding their needs and you know
you got looks like the clients are ours
even like like on the phone for hours
talking through things and figuring
things out and and a lot of iteration a
lot of feedback from them so it's really
fun so would you say Rails was one of
the key inspirations for you starting a
podcast around open-source I mean rails
is one of the most important open-source
projects it's brought so many people
into the field it revolutionized yeah a
lot of crud based web apps were built
for fare so a little piece of the
history is so the person that I hired to
work with me on the rail site his name's
Josh Owens he's pretty prominent in the
JavaScript and I believe like meteor
space now I think he still lives in Ohio
I can't recall maybe Columbus area
he had a podcast that would began in
2004 called the web 2.0 show so I don't
know if you know this Quincy but at one
point the web was just one point now and
then then it became 2.0 and that just
meant that we had gradients and like
rounded corners and what version are we
on at this point that who knows you know
who knows don't use an html5 and css3 as
you go that's right
and so he had a show a podcast called
the web 2.0 show it was one of the very
earliest first technical or tech or
software focused podcast and at that
time you didn't have to do much because
you just had to be a podcast you could
be terrible quality sound wise great
content it didn't matter you had all the
listeners because there was no one else
doing it and so his partner had quit and
this is how I got into podcasting and
more specifically how I got into like
talking to people that weren't just like
my buddies nearby about software
technical related things and so I became
his his co-host I think in like late
2005 early 2006 I literally been
podcasting since like 2005 I can say
2005 ago there's at least like November
2005 but not all the whole year but I
can claim 2005 yeah Wow they were on the
ground floor yeah podcasting as
medium yeah yeah I mean in a lot of ways
I mean I came over using a really crappy
snowball was like a white microphone it
was crappy to me because you could see
the mix we're using now and over time I
had to learn about audio to things that
I never even really cared to learn about
that you sort of had to had to be forced
to learn these things just by way of
producing audio and now you have to
deliver a show that sounds really good
we used to get away with it before we
can like not that we wanted to but we
could ship something to our listeners
that wasn't immaculate sound quality you
know but now we kind of feel like we're
because of what listeners desire and
demand and because so many people are
doing it well and it's also a lot easier
to produce a well you know now I
couldn't think of like shipping like if
you go back and listen to the web 2.0
show you wait here what I'm talking
about
but yeah yeah even even some of the
earlier episodes is the changelog
listening to him I mean there's it's
just night day yeah today in the
production quality it's it's funny you
go back and listen to episode number one
and then even go from one just to just
100 just go on the under hundreds go to
one 100 200 and 300 what were like 367
will ship this week I believe so yeah
the way the way the cheese look came
about was was I was working with a buddy
named Wayne Netherland and when
Netherland when Netherland and Kylie the
Netherlands but Netherland and I think
he used to say that too he goes by
penguin PNG w-why nn on Twitter so look
him up but he was at an interesting
space because he ran a consultancy
called squeegee now winds got some
really interesting witty humor so it was
called squeegee because he liked to like
clean things and make things nice and
their brand was like a lot like you
might imagine like a cleaning products
brand so like kind of like shiny and
shiny and it was really interesting
I loved all of that aspect about him but
he was in his crossroads because he had
just decided to leave his consultancy
and sort of like go a new direction and
so did I and so we were sort of both in
this sort of like let's establish our
name first
that's kind of like you know H on some
new territory and obviously I had a
background in at least doing something
with podcasting and so like talking
about things and that's like what if we
were both talking about how fast open
source is moving and I'm like you know
what people just need is they just need
like a Wayfinder through the versions so
if something changes if you know rails
1.0 versus 1.8 or whatever might be you
know somebody just needs to certainly
Chronicle the changelog of a pot of a
software product or software open source
whatever like someone needs to sort of
like tell that story and that's what
what's missing what happened here and
what happened here and what's happening
between people don't have that and such
like what if we just did a show called
changelog so it was just changed on the
first and it was like what about let's
change like to the changelog yeah yeah
and so we were the changelog and as a
matter of fact it's really funny because
it began is we still own these domains
yeah when did you get changelog calm
because that's a really good domain yeah
it took a little years and it wasn't
very expensive but there's a story
behind their had the chainsaw calm yeah
it because change logs show calm and
that was actually what our original
Google account was set up under our
email was actually Adam at change log
show
and then we aliased the change log calm
and then eventually I'm like you know
what we just need to shorten it to just
change log on Twitter and wherever we
can and so we only really did that
because they became available to us
somebody on Twitter gave that handle to
us thank you I can't recall you but we
wrote about this is never about somebody
on Twitter actually responding they just
voluntarily or they just gave it to us
yeah they were they were in software and
so they liked what we're doing they're
like I see that you're gonna use it for
good things it's not like you just want
it cuz you're some jerk or whatever and
so they knew we had good intentions
changelog calm was owned by somebody
else in software and they I don't think
they were really interested in selling
it until I made him an offer and then he
agreed to it we got we got changed all
dot-com for $1000 Wow $1000
what year was that I want to see like
2015 maybe not that long ago
yeah maybe 2014 and word 2014 these are
so chill people because I mean that's a
great day yeah he could have he could
have seemed like well right from the
wall you've been doing this for a while
you're probably gonna keep doing this
year you know I want more than a
thousand bucks but yeah it sounds like
he believed in the mission if he had to
give you that kind of price
yeah I don't think he believed in the
mission I think he just saw us as
someone who could do something with it
that wasn't just I guess I don't know
just something useful and we were
willing to give him what he what he
desired which was a thousand bucks and
we ended up using c2s II do to do the
sort of like the whole in you know
what's the the escrow kind of situation
where we put the money in there he is
able to collect the money or whatever
and then it's it's a nice easy way so I
recommend if you're gonna buy the man
from somebody I don't have all the
details but that's how we did it I would
use I would do it that way if you don't
know the person do it with some sort of
like exchange scenarios somebody in the
middle that can facilitate it and I
don't know if they would actually like
press charges that they didn't fall
through but there's something there's
some sort of commitment well that escrow
in the middle that yeah hold the phone
yeah yeah I mean it's especially if it's
like an international transaction yeah
its court you go to yeah dispute things
you know yeah that smart change lot like
ah was pretty cool we we even had it was
a big move you hope yet all that mm-hmm
so tell us some of the technical parts
of that suppose I was five years ago
it's like a lot of lot a lot of redirect
lottery tricks before we dig in all that
so of course I listen I had to listen to
the first episode oh oh well changelog
for doing the research did you like it I
mean it was it was pretty rough like
I've got a got a podcast wall that just
makes it really easy to pull up old
podcasts I don't know how they archived
it cuz even when I go on like iTunes and
try to scroll all the way down it
doesn't go all area which kind of is
disappointing there are some reasons why
and thanks detailin sorry oh but yeah
yeah but uh I was able to find it and
pull it up and we'll link to it in the
show notes if you wanna you know listen
to stay here that's really easy
calm / one yeah oh yeah that's a good
path but yes of David bear wind I'm
sorry I mean Evelyn yeah and sounds like
really cool guy he ultimately went to
get a job at github right yeah there's
some story there - he can go into a
little bit of that so when I became
close friends we had actually done some
some teaching together so when was more
developer less designer and less
front-end but he really had a an eye for
aesthetic and an eye for design and he
loved to always tinker and he was if I
described he was always like a
minimalist approach to things but not
you know he wasn't the kind of
developers like I can't touch CSS or he
just loved it like dive into things and
he just threw out that that and so we
did a we did a class at lowest or Ruby
conference in a couple other places I
wanna I want to say called design I for
the dev guy or gal and it's quite a name
which was yeah it was pretty funny and
so we wanted to do is like just help
software developers who are just
primarily in encode and back-end type
stuff and not at all in the front-end
feel a bit more comfortable with early
technologies like SAS pre-pre compilers
stuff like that and this is early days
of SAS this is even before like the SCSS
syntax so like this was super early days
so one side small tangent would be that
before there was the change like I
actually wanted to do a SAS podcast but
nobody would do it with me so I died on
that sword and instead decided to do
this this show the change law because I
had a partner who would be willing to
work with me on this so there you go no
one was really interested in the SAS
really want you just do a CSS show and
there's CSS tricks and I'm like yeah but
Chris is nobody I'm just kidding right
Chris is not nobody he's the man yeah
that's right that was like 2009 though
so like we're CSS tricks is today to
where it was then oh yeah
an amazing job so it just we were all
early days and that was like before it's
where it's at now and so there was just
the Fiat was more green there was a lot
more opportunity you know in terms of
like making Harvey English right whereas
now like we wouldn't start a front-end
focused website or podcast like that
like Chris would do you know because
something started doing it doing it well
we would do something else that where
there's a hole to fill not not to cramp
in on something else's style yeah you
know open-source was clearly something
that needed some yeah it was moving so
fast github I mean this the show began
in 2009 and github had just become a
thing in 2008 and a little bit more
history going one layer deeper so on the
web 2.0 show we actually met up with
Chris wants trough and TP dubs Tom
Preston Warner three months after github
was founded Wow and we had them on the
web 2.0 show so if you wanna go back and
listen to some really interesting old
days of github not owned by Microsoft
not bought for billions like dreamers
like these were developers who were like
wow we somehow found a way to tie in
like this front end and this
collaboration and get and like it was
before all these visions and dream had
come to fruition like they have for the
inventive writing Qwest and so that's to
me that's supercool that that's what
really got me into like loving this
medium was because even with our show we
can go back and like Chronicle the path
of some developers you know we've had
some people on four times three times
several times we've seen not only their
changes as as individual people but the
software they command are the things
they maintain the communities they lead
it is really interesting I love the fact
that we get a chance to be kind of what
that drill sergeant was to me to me the
encourage er right we like to shine our
light in places where it's not always
being shot shined and just encourage
people to press forward to congratulate
them for working really hard
I mean Tina's who don't get any things
we love to pat him on the back and say
keep going you're doing awesome job and
just do what we can to put more focus on
the things they're working on
fun fact so github had their own podcast
in the very very early days of github
called get explosion which was chris
wanstrath and person Warner and PJ Hyatt
the three founders of github basically
just sitting in a room and talking to
each other it was very low rent and it
was very raw yeah I think it's
disappeared off the internet once they
probably raised funding and started to
listen to that it was like it was very
wrong I loved it I just thought that
when you talked about their days with no
show
they actually had their own show about
git and github and then they really just
hung out anyways yeah if you can find
that send us links I'd love to listen to
it again it's some interesting content
well yes my god
I'm sorry I didn't mean to have one more
layer to his story though in speaking to
github in podcast we were actually
syndicated for a while on to github.com
slash explore ah so for a while they're
like they you know this is early days
too so they they were just they love
what we're doing
they love the changelog a little what
we're trying to do about open source and
Sharon you know all the things happening
and they're like let us help you somehow
and so they syndicated the the most
recent five episodes were on github.com
slash explore now it's not there anymore
so if you go there don't be disappointed
I am but you know if anybody github
wants to you know reignite I'm just
kidding but no that's some prime real
estate right there yeah it was such an
interesting time then too because that
github was not at all the github it is
today which doesn't mean is bad or good
it just means that it was interesting
because we could work with the it was
ran by developers and not like Oh
business people were bad but it was like
people who want to help other developers
do well and do cool things they were
willing to share you know what they were
doing and and prop up the show for a
while their people actually thought that
Sheen's lot was owned by github that's
how closely things were and so it's just
an interesting time I appreciate the
time we're on explore but it was just
really interesting that they were able
to share that and it was developers who
ran it not some bureaucrats or VC that
didn't have this humanity connection to
us as software developers just trying to
like at that time this show was just a
hobby like it was
after that it became a business for like
a better turns yeah you know yeah and
that's what I'm really excited to talk
about next so of course there was kind
of like urban dictionary has this
definition of this word called pod fade
yes essentially a podcast will start
publishing less and less frequently and
maybe they won't admit to themselves
that they're that the best days of the
podcast are behind them but maybe they
are kind of heading towards the door so
to speak so oftentimes with the pod fade
there will be a long gap and there'll be
one last episode in which the podcast
announces that it's returning is when
you know that's that the last episode in
the feet is they want the apology sorry
we've been so quiet we're back and
that's that's the end but I was on
YouTube too
yes we had that but we continued yeah so
let's talk about that struggle for the
soul of the changelog okay so slight
Baxter on that too so win and I both met
this guy named Josh Cofer who was
starting a non-profit he actually met
win first and win and I were both
freelancing as I mentioned and doing the
cheeseball podcast as a hobby fun thing
just to do and and when men was building
his team for pure charity this this
nonprofit that Josh Cooper was forming
to be a place for nonprofits to coalesce
to get information on how to best
fundraise how to lead their charges how
to unify their followers their
supporters for lack of better terms win
was like first you know one of the first
picks that was a second hire after him
so I guess I was first pick
he's like Adam do you want you know do
you want to do this it's kind of thing
and so next thing you know we're working
for this you know this nonprofit called
pure charity and women was CTO
I think I was like you know UX design or
something like that I don't remember
what my title was doesn't matter the
point was was that we were just sort of
like fleshing out our careers a bit more
and about two years pass and the majors
call write wins in the farm club at pure
charity the majors github calls and says
hey win
you want to come up to San Francisco we
want to talk to you about some things
and so long story short he got called to
the majors he couldn't say no it was it
was we both love what we're doing at
Pierre charity but he couldn't say no to
it yeah and it was a you know like any
podcast it's just a hobby you only have
so much love for it and so much time for
when you have family you know you've got
your career you got other things and so
it was like hey I'm out of time I just
can't do this anymore
and I think that was around September
2012 and and and I was kind of bummed
I'm like hey I get it I don't have a lot
of time for it either and then I set in
this sort of law for a while just
thinking like you know it's not worth
much but would anybody want to buy it
like should I keep it going what should
I do with it you know I know it's I know
what it means to so many people and what
it could mean if we just keep it going
and so I was just really in this whole
space where I was just questioning
whether it made any more sense for me
because I'm definitely you know more on
the design front inside than developer
side and Jared has to remind me all the
time to drop my imposter syndrome and
say dude you're developer because I at
least even right now I felt less
developer than I had been before but I
was always more on the front end user
experience sort of like biz dev side of
things relationship side of the things
how should it look how should a function
how could we deliver it then the follow
through then the doing part of of
software and I've worked with great
people but it's just not where I shine I
can do it but I shine better in other
areas and so I was like am I an imposter
by just keeping this thing going what
can I do yeah man that is some hardcore
imposter syndrome and I totally yeah
there's definitely been deaths with free
code camp as well where I felt like
total imposter yeah but thank goodness
you didn't sell it because I there's no
way that anybody could have taken it
over and brought it to such heights as
it is today but thank you so that's
something I'm extremely grateful for
that you stuck with it yeah so you stuck
with it and a phone call or yeah that's
the story behind jared entering the
stage I'll tee it up to you and you
continue
yeah my tip is super short he emailed
win yeah and win for the email to me
how's it yeah so I was a listener and I
was tracking the blog so when has an
uncanny skill of finding new things
the gems yeah he could find gems and you
know over the years I've tried to
imitate that and I've gotten pretty okay
at it I can I like to find things to you
know new open source project here a new
technique a great blog post and so I was
following the blog mostly I was I'm also
a podcast junkie was back then still and
that's why I know about get Splosion
where most people don't even realize
that was a podcast I'm like the github
guys have a podcast I'll listen to it
and so I was a listener of the show and
I really appreciated the blog because I
was in Omaha Nebraska
doing my thing writing software for
people and I very much felt like I was
on an island so to speak in the open
source world I cut my teeth on UNIX and
Linux and networks and I was a vim guy
early on I was just always in open so
like I learned Perl then I learned Ruby
and then rails blew my mind then I was
building rails websites and so I was in
the open-source universe I didn't even
really realize that like there was much
else even though it is this entire
Microsoft side of things I just didn't
people started talking about c-sharp and
I didn't know what they're talking about
early on and then it started to fade and
the blogs were coming less than us often
and the podcast was happening in less
and less and I was running my own a
single-person consultancy basically
making web apps for people and I had
known win because of Ruby I believe I
think he had a ruby gem that I used and
I came from which one it was he actually
was involved in the Twitter gem for a
while yeah it was and I remember I had
you know contributed to that and then
basically we fought each other on
Twitter and I started listen to his
podcast and he started reading my blog
or something anyway we were just mutual
connections there and I didn't even know
about Adam very much except for he was
the guy that was always talking to win
win did a lot of the interviews on the
show back then I knew that Adam was
involved in the changelog and when the
changelog was winning
I didn't know who Adam was a new who win
was and so when it started to fade out
basically I had the capability of just
helping out with the blog because I had
my own business and so I could fill in
gaps and I could do that kind of work
and so I just offered I just emailed win
I was like hey I see you guys are like
struggling to keep it going
can I help you no because I can I can
blog once a week or whatever it is and
so we net I think had actually moved on
already I just it was all behind the
scenes he was already working in github
or something and so he just forward and
he's like hey man thanks for reaching
out and he forwarded me to Adam and
Andrew who's also co-host at the time
yeah cuz they injury I worked together
pure charity as well yeah Andrew Thorpe
and so that's how I got involved was was
through that yeah I didn't want to see
you die a listener this could be you
this is this is this reminds me of like
the story of like you know Judas Priest
sell like the Rob Halford had to leave
the band for whatever reason and they
found a guy who was running the he he
was the singer of a tribute band for
Judas Priest okay he became the
Cinderella story it sounds kind of like
this was a Cinderella story you're
listening one day you're listening to
the changelog the next day you're on the
changelog yeah it was very surreal the
first time that I was on the show
because I wrote for the website for a
while before I was on the show because
Andrew was a pure charity Andrew moved
on to stripe I think he went to yeah he
went to work at stripe wasn't gonna
co-host anymore and eventually I came
into the co-host row but I remember the
first time I was on it was like a
reunion episode yeah me you Stevie
Clinic never eats
yeah Kenneth reeds and Andrew was on the
show as well yeah five of us and we were
just kind of shooting the poop is
supposed to be live every week and it it
was the first and only live show yeah I
could be wrong but but we had ambitions
but I was very strange hearing my voice
on the show that I'd been listening to
for all those years you know that was
back in 2012-2013 time range yeah it was
when I got involved so yeah well give us
a little bit more background about
yourself because to even get in the
position where you were contributing to
these these libraries or like the
Twitter Jim for example when I used
early on as a developer as well so I
didn't even realize it until you said it
but I've used
your code yeah how did you how did you
ramp up what's your what's your origin
story so it's someone humorous to me
that you're asking both of us about our
origin stories we used to do origin
stories on the show it's true in fact
you were on the show about four years
ago we don't have got yours or an origin
story as well and we stopped doing those
over time because we found that they
were kind of hit or miss the first one
that I remember was Kong or mashape I
think akhmad in Austria yeah he had an
amazing origin story I myself and I was
like Adam this guy had animate we have
to ask everybody their origin story
that's so cool and then we started
asking more and more people and it
became they were like somebody would
have an amazing one the other one would
be very boring and straightforward and
so that's what you're running into right
now because Adam just had his origin
story from poverty and the military and
all these things and my origin story is
very status quo for somebody in America
and growing up in the 90s I was raised
by two parents who love each other and
loved me this coming up on their 50th
anniversary in the suburbs of middle
America a pretty typical public school
education you know went to college
learned some stuff got into tech got
into technology and and Here I am I mean
there's not much there's not much to dig
into that's unique or different and so I
don't I don't think we need to cover too
much well the one piece of your history
I do like that's kind of interesting is
is the government job you have plan for
you after school that's it that's an
interesting caveat that I don't know how
much you want to share about sure that's
an interesting caveat to your story yeah
absolutely so there there are some
things in there that that we might be
able to to dig into so I've always
considered myself to be a cautious a
cautious opportunist and so when I see
opportunities in my life I just kind of
cautiously go into them versus either
like rambunctious lis going in or
jumpered in or go or not go in so like
that's kind of where I've been and even
with the changelog this was not like I
decided hey this is gonna be a new part
of my career I was just more like I
could contribute to the blog like
I saw need and I kind of started Danna
just like slowly slowly steamrolled and
so that's the story of my education as
well I didn't I wasn't into software I
wasn't into technology I got my first
computer I was eighteen years old which
was relatively late for a lot of
developers the only thing I did on it
was Napster you know pretty much and
then I played video games a friend of
mine in high school told me I should
apply for a scholarship there's a thing
in Omaha called the Walter J Scott
scholarship Walter Scott is a guy who's
done very well for himself and has a
scholarship for certain students to go
into technology industry and then stay
in Omaha is kind of his deal that's cool
I had never heard of it my friend said
hey you should try this out it's an IT
thing and I was like I T what's that is
you know I said internet things right I
mean I was actually planning on being an
architect that was but I wasn't like
passionate about art you know in school
they kind of like make you pick
something and I had done pretty good on
the CAD machine like I could draw a draw
thread you know I remember my my CAD
design teachers like you're gonna make a
great architect one day I'm like okay
I'll be an architect and that was like
the extent of my passion for
architecture but I was like okay I could
do that looking back I think I was just
good at manipulating the computer to
make it a thread design not the actual
design itself so that's why I just
better at CAD than I was at architecture
because I I do have a knack for these
things but I just didn't know it anyway
is my friend Chad told me about this
scholarship and my friend Aaron had
gotten the scholarship a year earlier
it's for people who test pretty well on
on scores and Aaron tested very well and
I thought if he could do it I could do
it that was kind of my my attitude so I
applied for the scholarship got the
scholarship and it included you know
like a computer and stuff like that full
right to you and University of Nebraska
so that was really cool
and that's really what got me into
software at all I was management
information systems
I was it's which is kind of like
computer science but it's not computer
science it's like they try to sell is
the best of both worlds of like business
and computer science together I found
out that's actually
means like the least of both of those
worlds right like you're not a computer
scientist person either and so it's kind
of like just a lukewarm version of
either of those other majors right don't
recommend it just go computer science if
you are gonna go to a four-year school I
second that
yeah position or just start off recode
camera uh and I didn't really learn yeah
its second I would encourage people to
still go to school if you have the
resources to go to school yeah I would
too
all those lots are out so I actually
I'll say this everybody needs something
a little bit different and so for some
people a free code camp is like 100
percent the way to go even if they have
the resources for some people a boot
camp like a in person immersive but
still short thing is great way to get
started they can go from there for other
people they may need you know a
four-year degree before they go into it
your age matters your life circumstance
matters absolutely and so there really
is not like a a single solution to rule
them all which is why I love how many
options there are and how it's like a
ecosystem anyways a little bit off topic
I like that that I mean a lot of facets
to how you can learn that's what's
important there right the important
thing to communicate is there's not one
way that that rules all it your way may
be different than mine or Jerez or
Quincy's and it's just a matter of
persevering through it eating over the
humps and hurdles right that sometimes I
mean that's why it's hard because hard
things if it was easy everyone would do
it it's hard because it's worth doing so
persevere find some friends or your
tribe to you know guide you through or
support you through you know get people
around you mentors all that stuff so
there isn't one with it's the best fit
for everybody yeah so I cautiously
walked into that opportunity and it
worked out and that moved me off the
architecture track and into the computer
world so to speak I didn't really learn
very much about computer systems in the
first few years of my college that's
just a unfortunate fact some of that was
me a lot of that was the school my last
year I found another potential
scholarship and I liked scholarships
because it's free fun and this one was
cool so one cool thing about the Walter
Scott scholarship is it's
stackable and there's actually a term I
came from what it is but certain ones
you get like a full ride and you're done
you can't actually get other
scholarships well for enterprising
students who would rather get
scholarships than like jobs like myself
you could find one stack and if you can
get those then you're basically getting
more money so I found another
scholarship called the National Science
Foundation scholarship for service and
it was all about information assurance
and so this was like a push into getting
some of these CS people and Mis people
into software security so assurance that
your software information assurance yeah
but it's got quality assurance and
information security yeah patched up
exactly it's like how sure are you can
you can we be sure about our systems and
so it was very much a a government thing
it was two years of schooling which was
stacked on top of my other scholarship
with a concentration on information
assurance which was a new thing at the
University of time I think is still
exists but it's basically I learned
penetration testing securing and
hardening systems does you know
defense-in-depth all these security
concepts and then I was supposed to go
into to attach to that is two years to
work with a government agency upon
graduation so it was really great I
actually learned a lot in that program
you learn the the really nitty-gritty of
how systems work networks especially and
how insecure they are in ways that you
can pick those things apart upon
graduation there was a hiring freeze in
the in the government and so we had a
circumstance where you know sometimes
the right hand doesn't know what the
left hand is doing well on the right
side of the government's hand they were
creating a new scholarship for service
to get all these new bright young minds
to go work for a three-letter agency and
on the left hand side they had a hiring
freeze on so we were the first class
that did the scholarship there's 200 of
us nationwide and there were no jobs for
us but we had this agreement yeah
commitment a two-year commitment
and so isn't like make you peel potatoes
for two years well they wanted us to
wait sit around and wait really they
expected you to wait for just two years
before starting your career
yeah sit around and wait so that was
unfortunate so I was in this weird like
no-man's land where I was graduating I
had this commitment but there was no job
to actually fulfill a commitment and so
what was I supposed to do well in that
timeframe this is like when I was in the
21 to 23 time reign time range at a 22 I
became a Christian and I started to
attend a local Bible Church in Omaha and
I really felt like it was important for
me to stay there while I was there I met
the pastor who's also an IT guy and ran
a software company with a networking
need and he was like I'll put you to
work and he was great really like yeah
in fact you can work for me as long as
you want and then if they come knockin
then you can just leave like you know
most people eat hard to find job in that
place cuz I like by the way I might have
to quit at any moment's notice and go
work for the government he was like he
did that for me Wow stand-up guy yeah
he's spectacular changed my life in many
ways that guy his name is John Malone
and he also thought it was ridiculous
that they were basically holding this
commitment to us and so he helped me
petition the school in the system and
basically they let a lot of us just off
our commitment because there's no jobs
and so he was instrumental in you know
providing for me during that time period
and then also helping me to get that
commitment raised and so I just kept
working for him I was like well this
worked out pretty well
he helped me out when I was in a bind
he's a software guy he from way back in
the day he knows all the the nuts and
bolts of like the old-school software
guys and he's got work for me to do so I
just worked for him for a while I was
never really a consider myself a
programmer back then I was kind of like
a networking scripter I can assert
myself a scripter it's funny how
reluctant people are to consider
themselves
like I'm not quite a developer I know
like I took some of the developer like I
took C++ and I see programming which I
should like to more than C++ we can we
could talk about that boy and I learned
Perl and as a penetration tester as a
person who's like trying to break into
systems and stuff or find holes or even
as a script Kitty like there's a reason
why they're called script kiddies is
because they don't have the skills of a
cat but they got the scripts and so I
would learn scripts I would read scripts
I would write scripts I consider myself
like an Automator and so I wrote a lot
of Perl scripts and then I found the
Ruby programming language I was like why
would I write Perl scripts when I can
write Ruby scripts under the spiritual
successor to Ruby yeah yeah borrowed a
lot of the great things from Perl and
then discarded some of the things some
of the warts and so I started writing
Ruby I knew some piranhas some Ruby I
consider myself a networking guy like I
ran some mail servers and I would
automate a lot of things around that job
so while I was working for John I
automated a lot of the things that he
had for me to do on the network and so I
could eat a twiddle my thumbs at work
because I had automated all my my
responsibilities or I could continue
learning my skin you know establishing
my skills and so I was tweaking
WordPress blogs mostly my blog it's kind
of like pimp my blog early in the day
yeah where I had this blog is probably
slightly better than Adams in terms of
like content cuz it was like a I was
trying to write interesting things it
wasn't what you said it's like family
photos and stuff pretty much a little
bit more get an occasional personal
thought but yeah things very profound
and I was writing about software and
just blogging and I really want is a
wordpress site I really wanted my latest
I remember when I started to realize you
know I can just program websites there's
like a flip in my mind and it was a I
wanted my most recently played iTunes
songs in the sidebar of my blog because
back and this is the blogosphere day you
were trying to share kind of the little
things I wanted to pick my blog and one
of the cool stuff in my sidebar and so I
had to basically start writing PHP like
I wrote a wordpress plugin or something
like that and it talked to the you know
the the iMac
my house I came from exactly the details
and I got it done you know and that was
really cool and then I was like okay
what else can I do with my blog you know
started like integrating the Flickr
stuff in just right all these master not
Instagram Flickr
that's right back in the Flickr days all
the Matt we're just mashing stuff up
back and that was the cool thing open
API is mash him up come with something
new I love that stuff yeah and so that's
when I started thinking you know what I
could just do this for other people
because it's pretty cool and I saw the
power of the web platform really and I
was like every business needs something
like this there were could or could be
advantage by having one like today it's
kind of table stakes to have a certain
you know web presence but back then
we're talking 2006 it was not table
stakes it was advanced it was a
competitive advantage you know so I
started helping people do that kind of
stuff I learned Ruby on Rails and
because I had this job where I was doing
networking but also this boss who is
like hey you've you've achieved all
these goals that we need if you can go
make money another way go ahead and go
do that and so I started bringing
basically freelance consulting clients
into his business and operating on like
a one-on-one basis with them and I did
that for years and that's kind of from
that mill eventually I I went out on my
own and started my own entity doing very
similar work bought my customers from
him but you know still great friends to
this day it wasn't like that started
doing it on my own and in that
circumstances when I was like Flyway a
bird fly away yeah exactly
you're graduated yeah so yeah under
those circumstances I could help out
with the changelog and so that's in 2012
is when I hooked up with Adam and when
you know you're hearing this somewhat
for the first time right I mean and kind
of I am too it's I'm kind of mind
blowing that what's interesting about
the story success right this overnight
success actually took many years and
then you when you dig into the details
you get to see all the little things
that sort of had to happen to make
things yeah success or happen right like
if Jared wasn't fortunate enough in
those way
is to have a good friend given that
opportunity him thrive in it and then
excel at it to a point where he can
actually go off on his own and have that
freedom and flexibility well jeez I mean
he would have never emailed when I would
have probably Cod faded forever right
you know and it would have been just a
dead dog yeah you're right I mean so
what I'm getting from hearing your
respective origin stories is there are
so many people along the way yeah who
were almost guardian angels in a way and
cleared the path for you to go toward
your destiny of running the changelog
together yeah one more aspect that your
story that he's not sure yet which he
might is the same person John told him
what an a communicator he was that's
right and he's the person that sort of
like gave that insight the jurors so
sometimes you have these these true is
about you but you don't know right it's
kind of weird to like know you but not
know all of you and somebody else sees
this thing in you and he shares this
with Jared that he's a really good
communicator to tell a story of course
but you know and it's sort of like gave
Jordan new perspective on right how he
could be as good as he is in software
and technology but then also a good
communicator and to bridge those two
yeah so that's one of the insights that
John gave me at some point camera
exactly when I've been working for him
for a while I'd known him for a while
and we were good friends and he saw my
programming skills which are you know I
would say average to slightly above
average like I can I can throw down but
I'm not gonna blow anybody away okay
there's hundreds if not thousands of
better developers out there maybe tens
of thousands I don't know you don't yeah
we don't measure these things point is
is like could I be the best software
developer in the world no but I can hold
my own and then on the other side with
communication skills and the ability to
write well ii think you know off the top
of your head to speak to people in ways
that they understand am I the best at
that no I'm not the best at that either
but there's very few people that kind of
play in both of those playgrounds I mean
the stereotype of a developer which I
believe we're finally starting to break
out of that mold and I love it there's
so many different kinds of developer
but it's like the the antisocial you
know person in their basement very
doesn't want to talk to people once I
just I just want to code all day and
drink Mountain Dew like that stereotype
there's some truth in stereotypes right
generally there's truth and then
specifically they're wrong they're false
but the general truth there is that
developers are not the best
communicators and so there's very few
good developers who can also communicate
and so John said to me I didn't realize
any of this I'm looking back at it
realized and he said where you're going
to succeed in this industry is that you
can be you can bridge the gap between
developers and communication skills
mm-hm
and I was like oh cool maybe you're
right oh cool and then it's like well a
podcast about software development yeah
I guess that does kind of make sense in
retrospect so yeah he definitely made me
aware of that as a possibility you know
I didn't even think about it so yeah
we've had you know everything everybody
has influencers or enablers or you know
that drill-sergeant it says you're a
leader now yeah I think everybody has
those stories and sometimes it takes
introspection and reflection to actually
think about that you know because so
much we're just like iterating forward
you know and not looking back so lots of
people yeah thank God for him to me geez
you know that's why I think it's so
important if you're in that position
that's why I made that point earlier in
to make it again is that if you're in
that kind of position
to to enable somebody what a blessing it
is to enable somebody the feedback loop
is nice it's a nice to have it's not a
need to have in if you're in that
position because just help people along
the way I mean I can't even imagine how
many people have listened to your show
or our show or have been influenced by
free code camp or the changelog or
whatever we're doing that we've never
even heard of that like their lives have
literally changed and we don't even know
yeah you know we just gonna show up
every day do what we do you know if we
still gonna do it do it if they say
we're gonna be there be there and just
help people to find respect you know
compassion empathy and
and sometimes even the benefit of the
doubt well yeah not everybody's bad in
other ways good but finding that balance
and encouraging somebody and being that
person that's that's what I that's what
I love most about what we do is is being
able to influence people's lives and to
love on people and I know we're not
we're not to that part of the interview
yet but I'll just say the impact that
you've had with free code camp in the
first five years we'll get into that
later yeah I mean it's it's amazing to
watch what you've done there and and the
amount of people's whose lives you've
helped it's it's astounding I mean I've
read those numbers that you put in that
blog post and I was just like wow that's
this is some serious impact and like you
know that tide is rising a lot of people
ships and it's it's really cool so thank
you for opps to you all no thanks I'm
trying to be consistent yeah three seas
right yeah yeah this is something that I
I had kind of just kind of recognized
whenever I thought about the recipe for
success when it comes to producing a
podcast or basically any sort of piece
of content you have basically three C's
you got quality content or just content
to you produced on a consistent basis to
a community of people so if you're
producing content that's good that
people want to consume enjoy share like
whatever it might be on a consistent
basis or at least something where you
set an expectation you know hey I'm
gonna do a show every week and then
that's your that's your rhythm that's
your cadence and then if you wrap all
that around to a community or either
develop a community or do it for a
community then you're gonna have some
success because that's all it takes
you could be talking about knitting you
could be talking about software you
could be talking about cameras and
lighting you can be time-up microphones
whatever if you do that on that kind of
rhythm that kind of basis that kind of
focus you'll find success and that's and
that's not easy to do either no it's not
the three C's is it's nice to remember
them and it's
it is somewhat easy to say even though
you feel EQ in there it's nice yep but
it's easy to say but especially the
consistency part like you said Quincy
you're just trying to consistent yeah
and like even now we've transitioned
into like a full-blown business and like
we're established we've been here for
ten years but like consistency you know
quality content is hard as well I feel
like we've gotten better at that over
the years and you can you can develop an
eye for it and sometimes you still
strike out or in our case in here yeah
in the airport community is something
that comes naturally to people who
commune with other people so yeah yeah
you have to put effort into that and it
doesn't come without effort but it's not
as hard as you know consistency
consistency consistency is so hard and
that's why the pod veda is like a word
in urban dictionary I would say for me I
think the the harder thing is community
because it's not like Field of Dreams
building they come it's you've got to be
there you got to show up every day you
got to be invitation like consistency I
think it I find it personally for me
it's been a little easier to be
consistent with quality content uh-huh
and harder to be part of the community
and develop that yeah that's just you
know that's me just like with learning
you have different paths for me that's
the area where I fail more often I think
or don't thrive as well yeah well let's
talk about how Jared came on board and
you had a circumstances that were
propelling you to professionalize the
change yeah if you will well I think
when when left it certainly put a kink
in my thought pattern for like a hit
made some money you just enough to sort
of like you know server costs pay the
bills make it somewhat worth it it
wasn't like we could leave our full-time
jobs and even remotely he considered
doing that as a full-time thing you know
we had some early sponsors we'd work
with github early for different things
when they were promoting it up jobs you
know and even then we didn't have a keen
eye on how to best partner with brands
to help them share their messages in
ways that developers really want to hear
so relevance is one but then also not
objectifying like oh you should get that
you know just I don't know just finding
a way to humanize these businesses and
help them reach developers in ways they
just weren't able to another way it's
like it's not a display ad it's not this
or whatever and I think when it became a
business the the one thing for me
personally which is sort of embarrassing
to even mention as I mentioned I was a
freelancer for a while and didn't really
have a in quote job I was my own self
employer so to speak you know I didn't
do the best I could have done with
filing my taxes properly in paying my
taxes properly and you know thank God
the government has an option where you
can establish a payment plan and I did
but that didn't mean that the tax debt
was gone right away so I had accumulated
a little bit of tax debt having
essentially bloodied my knuckles as a
freelancer I didn't do things so well
learn learned how to do it better and
then corrected those things but yeah and
and this happens through a lot of
freelance yeah the US tax code is
complicated you know we still spend a
huge amount of time yeah that's even it
to like the difficulty of reporting it
especially as someone who's only
collecting 1099s that's really difficult
it really is and like you're so focused
on just like at least for me my
experience was so focused on just
showing up and doing that I felt like
gosh I just could tax us be a little
easier to do and so I just didn't do
them for like a couple years there's no
big deal but that the point was is this
what started to move into this full-time
business you know even an option for it
was you know one obviously we heard the
back story Jared and all these things
sort of orchestrating and coming to be
but then too I had just been recently
married my wife and I we met in 2010 we
got married in 2012 and this is around
that time I mentioned when stepped away
late 2012 and
let's say 2012 to 2013 was the years we
began to to formulate what has become a
business you know it been in place since
2009 didn't really become anything
business substance until 2012-2013 and
that's my wife saying hey you can't do
my wife just got helping me as a man
guard my time because as somebody who's
just ambitious you will often just throw
yourselves into things that you probably
shouldn't say yes to you probably just
say no more often and you know to help
me understand that and guard me from
that she said if you're gonna do this
we're gonna take time away from our
relationship our future etc you got to
find some way to make it make money you
know make it worth it and so what was
really interesting about that is having
the heart to love on and care for a
community and show up and do these
things basically for free no one
downloads a podcast and pays a buck
right it's all for free but somewhere
along the lines we've got to find a way
to make a business model or develop a
business model that can help us do what
we plan to do which is create this
awesome content and throw having a
community do it consistently like the
three CSA but have a model that allows
us to to operate that way and so that
was the hardest part was figuring out
what that model was it gets kind of easy
because sponsorship for podcast seems to
be the most typical especially now that
it's kind of become a thing you know
earlier 29 2009 2012 even in that era
there wasn't a lot of podcast it was
still early it was before cereal and the
big boom of podrace and whatever so you
know obviously it would make sense to
build a business model around run
sponsors now early version was like no
sponsors members only kind of thing and
in all honesty I would love to run a
membership driven only kind of business
that maybe not love it would be nice it
would be fortunate to do that but it's
just not it's just not enough to do what
we try to do and so especially back try
some different moments ride it yeah this
yes true this was pre patreon yeah this
was pre
really the modern era of the web where I
think people are more forward to support
things that they love because they don't
want them to go away back then it was
more random like it just wasn't
something that people are used to doing
yeah
and so maybe now it would be more
feasible whereas when we tried it right
which was around the time that I joined
20 2012 remember the announcement was I
wasn't there yet it was like member
supported only right and I was like
really and I was even a die-hard
listener I don't think I signed up like
it's really hard ass terrible I'm sorry
man my books it was a hard sell back
then maybe it's easier now but yeah so
so a membership program didn't work out
the way you hoped it would
but you were quick to adapt right well
we had to I mean if we were gonna so if
I was follow my wife's advice hey if
you're taking my time away from our time
with you know as a relationship and
growing our marriage then I've got to
find a way to make this succeed as a
business and I thought memberships will
work I was really hopeful that it would
I still as Jerry said I think we've
we've now come into a new world where
they're more possible and you also have
this sort of new change where people
want to support the things they love and
I think we have a small amount of people
globally that would want to give that to
us and I don't want to take that
opportunity away the problem I think was
that we were relying on that completely
as a business model and that just didn't
it just didn't work as a solo business
Molly they just it needed more more than
that and I think for us I mean there's a
lot of opportunity on the table there's
so many businesses out there that are
trying to reach software developers you
know staple partners of ours like Linode
digitalocean fastly roll bar get Prime
and help me if I'm forgetting some
because I mean it's not like a long
exhaustive list I'm trying to like thank
everybody a bit like some really strong
businesses that want to help brands like
ours do what we do and at the same time
reach an audience they couldn't
otherwise reach theirs that's something
that's something we can latch on to fast
they mentioned
particular hey if you listen to our show
you might have heard this phrase before
bandwidth for change levels provided by
fastly learn more fast calm you know we
move fast and fix things here change
light because a roll bar had to robot a
common chick had to roll what I come and
check him out and you know was the last
one that's right and so you know stole
that I have that idea from Leo Laporte I
mean gosh Leo Laporte is an icon in the
interesting podcast right tech podcast
right if you listen to their show you
know net cash you love trust from people
you love that's right chip on his
shoulder he got over it yeah yeah yeah
but then counter fly was one of their
core partners I'm like a wheat if so if
I want to build a business around this
we've got to find so I can be remember
talking to you about this something do
you think we can get somebody to do this
and give us money every month and and
like other people that advise us that's
probable I good luck what we did it you
know and we find ways to support our
business in ways that just I'm astounded
honestly and we're really fortunate
we've done a great job
you know forging not just sponsorships
like that's the sort of the industry
term that's known you know we're
interested in sponsorship whatever but
we look at it more like partnerships
you know we thrive our business even
personally we thrive on relationships
and so we want to work with brands that
know who we are know what we're trying
to do want to support that but then also
get paid a dividend by being able to in
an authentic way speak to the global
audience we've been able to cultivate
over these years right you know and do
that in a way that doesn't objectify our
audience or only come in for these
reasons like there's it's gotta be more
to it than just that you know and we
help them speak to software developers
in ways that that that are relevant yeah
I think it's worth pointing out that
podcast advertising really works in ways
that other forms of
heisting doesn't really work yeah and so
the medium is is suited very well for
that style campaign because you are in
you're going directly into people's ears
you know week by week time by time and
if you can be a staple and supporting
the show that people love and are
getting for free and so they I think as
listeners I'm a like I said I'm an old
podcast junkie I know a lot of the
sponsors who are supporting the shows
that I love and I am fine with
transferring a little bit of goodwill to
that company it's like yeah Casper
supports this show you know we a lot of
the the mainstream tech podcasts have
very the usual suspects of sponsors
right Casper Squarespace audible like
these are brands that have years and
years of goodwill because they've been
supporting the shows that I love and
because they have their hosts the people
that I love their shows talking about
their brands it's just a very effective
thing yeah and so people the reason why
I think podcasts are such a vibrant
ecosystem right now is it's very good
for consumers because it's on demand
niche like listen to what you want none
of the stuff you don't want
it's really low overhead for consumers
can create a radio in terms of ads like
compare it to the radio ads where
they're yell and su4 like gosh seven
minutes of the 30 yeah and then on the
pot on the actual sponsorship side they
really work these sponsorships work
whereas display ads and other things
just haven't had the ROI like the ROI is
there for the companies that believe in
it yeah we mean I would really help a
lot of businesses like that like a
recent example that I was really stoked
about was coop con so the cloud
commuting computing foundation has this
conference every I guess a couple times
a year sometimes in Europe sometimes
United States and we've been very good
friends with the Linux Foundation over
the years and then that also bleeds into
the cladding of computing foundation and
their conference coop con which we've
gone to we love going there we're
actually going back this year Gerhard
let's do is representing us this year so
that's awesome but we have just ran some
promos for them to promote hey if you're
thinking about attending use our code
save 10%
get the early bird pricing for extended
times whatever it might be and you know
join this kind of community and and help
them share that invitation with the
larger community and their feedback to
us was like your code was the most used
over all the people that we used in
these promotional wings and I just love
that because for one everybody attending
is to save ten percent but then to like
it's proof that we actually can help
willing community people in in the
software world to hear something on a
podcast and actually take action and
it's not like I'm selling Jerrod
something he doesn't want with money he
can't he doesn't have even something
generic right like if I'm listening the
go time and I hear an ad for coop con
like I'm super interested in coop con
like oh great it's coming up it's gonna
be in Brussels so I'm not sure where it
is but you know Amsterdam Amsterdam and
then you go go to that these are not
Burger King ads or alright crest you
know considered the impossible burger ad
though Mackin no I'm just kidding I'm
just kidding
so anyway it was a joke it's proven to
be a yeah a very viable model for
referral you know it really is a
win-win-win this is just to use Michael
Scott's phrase because the sponsors do
and our partners win yeah as of the
results like that we win because we're
making a living off of it and our
listeners get free shows consistently
quality content right and they you know
we put out 60 to 90 minutes shows and
you're gonna listen to two or three ads
in a 90-minute show we're not asking
very much yeah and those ads are
incredibly pointed and valuable like
it's content it's like oh that's
interesting I'm I'm interested on that
so it's not annoying it's yeah so I
think everybody wins I like the model
and that's like what they've found with
advertising is if it's relevant than
it's less awesome right and in this case
with podcasts podcast can be hyper
targeted like this is a podcast about
open source software right I mean you
could never get that level of great
variety with like TV that's right
yeah that's why some of the larger more
mainstream podcasts struggle with the
sales to the sponsors because they don't
have the targeted audience they have
huge audiences but they aren't targeted
so you'll hear a lot of mainstream ones
like even mainstream tech like the verge
cast which is a pretty mainstream tech
news
and commentary show they will you'll
hear them asking their listeners to take
surveys and stuff because they have a
more generic mainstream listener base
they don't know exactly who they're
talking to
well when you have a show called go time
about the go programming language and
kubernetes and these things you know
exactly who's listening to that show
yeah and so you don't have to survey
them you know that's the value of a
niche yeah speaking of go time I think
this is a perfect opportunity for me to
ask at what point so you had the
changelog yeah that is the granddaddy of
open-source podcast it's called our
flagship show that's products you show
and now you have several you have
several that we're shorter period like
request for commits which was one of my
personal favorites yeah learned a ton
from that one me too
but how did you go about creating
additional shows and and how do those
all work let me take this one go for it
okay so we've been working with Brian
Kittleson and Eric st. Martin of of go
freak on it was their second year
actually I think the reason we even did
the show
it begins because Brian Kittleson hopped
in our issues in and github in our pink
we had a pink repo where we would say
hey community if you have some ideas
suggestions whatever we've since moved
it to different ways but we used to have
a repo on our github or called ping
which is that's another win thing
honestly he's so awesome but Brian Kelso
reached out to us on our issues there
and said hey if you haven't thought
about it yet you should come to go freak
on this is our invitation to you and
that's what I love about Bryant is he's
like he's like the the mack daddy of
like and you can I'm showing my age here
- because that's he's the mack daddy of
like inviting people in right I love
that about Brian and Eric and he reached
out to us we had them on the Chiefs all
talking about Gopher con they invited us
up to their conference we went out there
and did some fun stuff if you go to
change all that com / films you'll
probably see some cool stuff you've
actually done some video work there with
them and
and and whatnot and so we just sort of
fell in love with the NGO community you
know they're really I would say
different than other communities because
they just they just seem very it's like
once you really how to describe it maybe
you can help me Jerry but just very very
protective and very close tight-knit
very tight-knit yeah there's the Aston
yeah and it's like once you're in you're
in and we just loved there you know that
conference everyone who went thread we
just loved how people collaborated and
mingled together and had fun together
was just such a fun conference and I
don't know if it was the conference in
the community but we just sort of fell
in love with that and we're like well
once we we've always had the desires to
expand we're like well the next one we
do make sense to be a go podcast of
sorts but Jared have you came up with a
name so I mean take it and take it from
there yeah what an amazing name it is -
it's go time
it's go time yeah it seems obvious in
retrospect naming is one of my favorite
things naming things as hard as we all
know as developers and so I love to do
it because I like challenges and
sometimes it takes a thousand bad names
for one good one to be born and we've
definitely been through those thousand
bad names because we have a portfolio of
shows now in addition to just the go
thing happening we have with the
changelog one opportunity a week to to
spawn just to spotlight something and we
it's very polyglot as you know as a
listener we don't have I mean open
source is kind of the crux of the matter
but we even go beyond that and we've
even changed the word to software
development in terms of the things that
we talk about because even though open
source basically permeates all software
development it's bigger than just open
source even now just because our
interests have grown over the years that
being said then that's 50 weeks a year
you know that's 50 shows a year if you
take a couple of weeks off and there's
so much more things to talk about
there's so much more things to spotlight
and we had a lot of listeners who's like
hey I love the change like I would love
to hear more but more about this topic
or more about that time because if we
covered go or a specific language even
for four weeks straight would be like
well did this turn into a go podcast or
are you still sort of multifaceted like
you like you say you are and so
you have to there's one way you can
diversify you can either diversify and
add more shows to that particular
podcast and just diversify by I guess
multiplication it just pizza for Israel
dividing by multiply 8 more shows a week
now changelogs young but then we would
have to have like series and like people
do seasons there's lots of different
ways of slicing it but what we thought
would be a lot cooler is instead of the
two of us doing more shows because you
hear our voices all the time anyways and
we're here to spotlight the guests like
we want more voices that's what we've
always been about when we had the
opportunity is like more voices more
people different voices and ours and so
lets you know it's extend our network
and our production skills and our the
tastes that we have and the interest
that we have to other people
and let's enable them to do shows me so
that's what it really became the
portfolio now some of us are on like I'm
on Jay s party regularly Adam has a show
called brain science that's himself and
Mariel Reece and so it's not like we're
not on those shows but we don't you know
you know it's not like the changelog
they're different shows they're
different people and we've been able to
expand the number of voices on our
network to much larger than ours and so
that's pretty cool I think yeah and one
thing that I think is really cool is you
figured out ways to take that kind of
like cool fractals logo and create
variations of like radial symmetry yep
each I mean I'm wearing the changelog
shirt yeah yeah this is my new one by
the way my old ones right here that I
got four years ago it's been washed
about a hundred times but for everybody
who's watching love it this is what it
looked like this is in that you've even
got a framed one over here but yeah Adam
sent me this after I was on the
changelog that's your old Google
credentials right there that's right the
og og yeah but the way that you've
branded them all and they've all got
really cool short punchy names and and
they have kind of a consistent sound and
a big part of that cohesive consistent
sound is brake master cylinder yeah can
you tell us about brake master cylinder
not much as we don't know much honestly
what the mysterious the mysterious a
great master cylinder what you know
it's interesting because I obviously
heard of brake master cylinder through
gimlet media and the work they've done
with reply-all and startup and other
shows so that's where I learned about
beep master cylinder and just one crazy
night on the Internet
like most things happen I was like just
figuring out brake master cylinder you
know the kind of stuff they're into
whatever and I'll turn up their website
and there's like an invite to reach out
and I didn't I thought was like typical
contact me kind of scenarios where you
reach out and they just never talk to
you alright there's no response
well like the very next day brake master
gets in touch and says I love what
you're doing let's work together I
didn't expect that that turns us into
this scenario where jarrod and I are
sort of riffing with brake master on
some different ideas for brand new music
for the changelog podcast and I think
was a good time in RC and the reason why
go time was so important so this was
kind of a a milestone for for me or like
okay we're gonna do this for real
because up into this point so the
original changelog had the California
song which is it has a tight story with
Adam and a band that he knows and all
that but then we also just had some like
Edwin go out on - I don't sound forest
or what are these websites like yeah
like the the sound equivalent of didn't
forest premium beat yeah and just buy
something you know and you get it it's a
royalty or it's a you pay ally slice
ease yeah but it's not an exclusive
license and so he would just pick music
he likes we put that in front of our
shows that would be our theme song it
was like that for a very long time and
in fact when we expanded from just the
changelog go time was our second show
when we did go time Adam found this song
that was that's all right it was beloved
it was uh probably on the first I don't
know 10 to 20 episodes yeah
no it's more like don't change anything
yeah so we had some resistance on that
one but what happened was because it's
just us a sound clip that you can buy a
license to anybody can do that
and it showed up in a commercial what
commercial wasn't Disney yeah Disney so
some of it was tasteful one of the go
time listeners is like why is the go
time theme song on this Disney
commercial and we were like okay
that was what it was like we have to get
our own music yeah it was and it
happened with our show our music on the
changelog - it was a John Deere
commercial or Jasmine lawnmower
commercial and it was like this grungy
rock kind of and then also that that can
put people off too if it's too rough
because it's really inviting inviting
art yeah everything our change about the
music so what was funny about that was
it become clear we weren't unique and
right if we had licensed music we
wouldn't be unique right so he started
working with brake master cylinder and
with the changelog and RFC which was a
great show and had I think to this date
the best the best deals like which we
don't use now because that shows are
tired but we should somehow we mix that
it was greenfield like ok people knew
the changelog song but we weren't trying
to like they weren't in love with it so
we could just start and with new shows
it's always brand new one with go time
the go time crew the listeners who free
said is a very tight-knit and
enthusiastic and like very active law
audience they already loved this song
and now we had to replace it with a
custom song and so we asked brake master
cylinder to basically like do a
different version like make a remix of
it make it brake master but make it us
but also make it kind of sound like the
ones already out there and some people
didn't even notice when we topped it in
but some people were mad some people
yeah we always want brake master hands
us anything to listen to I'm always like
doesn't have enough BMC in it can you do
it like these glitches like BMC is just
brake Masterson was just known for
certain things yeah
and or like can you bring in some of
these you know trademark brief massive
cylinder stuff so we always love you
know to speak very well a brake master
cylinder we keep saying this name we
don't know guy girl we're not sure if
it's one person many people we've never
met them we don't really have a first
name basis at all besides maybe brake
master that might be first man right
just cutting off selling your no but it
they're in our slack so hey if you if
you're out there you're like I want to
talk to brake master cylinder well gonna
change all the complex community doing
that hop in our slack and diem or say
hello that's just that easy but I'm
always talking to brake mass
about different stuff we're working on
or just catching up I'll just reach out
and say hey how you doing and we'll have
like a 20-minute conversation and like
three weeks go by and that happens again
or something like that so yeah but so
easy to work with so not even like what
I what often happens with creatives as
they're very attached
egotistical II to what they've done like
their creations are often a variation of
their identity with break masters
there's there's like I just you know if
they just throw it out there's like you
don't like that cool let's keep riff
let's keep rhythm this Corian they kind
of yeah professional detachment from
yeah their artistic work always willing
to like break masters the one of the
scenarios where I can see they always
deliver way more than you expect them to
if they just want to keep delivering
more and more value that's a that's a
lesson to be learned always deliver more
value to the people you're working with
and if you can't be no two reviews are
hard reviewing somebody's music that
they're creating for you is incredibly
different and it's custom and you don't
even know we don't even have the
language to describe you know I I'm
expecting from break master aside
similar to a code review or even a
feature review with the user you can
switch to yeah but you can't do that
like you're almost offended by how
juvenile that you know the feedback is
like it's part yeah exactly so when
you're trying to give feedback I can
imagine from the other side to like who
are these fools you know like I don't
like that high hat at eight seconds you
know like whatever like how do you we're
always like yeah it's not it's not
grooving enough you know make it a
little more cocky like the stuff you're
saying it's very difficult so yeah
extreme grace and they're talking like
time code and and and maybe even like
majors or minors right we're like take
that it's a wobble wobble take that
level level out of there
you know the naming is even cooler to
like when great mastering hands us new
stuff to listen to it's always got these
unique names attached to it and it's
like this one with a little bump bump
bump or something like the the finally
literally name some really interesting
stuff so it it's just a lot of fun
working with break master in and I'll
say you know having having done all of
our shows redone the song for the
changelog and all that stuff like having
only brake master cylinder stuff it
would be a sad day in our history
if
never got to have a break man and I'm
kind of getting a little bit weird about
it but like if something ever happened
to brake master and we couldn't ever
work with them again for whatever reason
whether it's they move on or something
bad happens who knows how it'd be really
it would be a day I mourn like I love
working with them and they produced the
best off and we wouldn't use any other
music besides brake master cylinder
newzik that's a that's a pretty strong
endorsement yeah yeah just because
they're just so easy to work with they
get our you get our DNA they get our
brand name they get what we're trying to
do and I just feel like they just add
this this special flare that like you'd
mentioned the artwork well there's a
reason why because we we sat down in a
room for two days basically in a bunker
with jake Stutzman and this is the guys
name Micah yeah I'm like I can't murmurs
last name though like a frost or Faust
something like that I can't recall but
Mike you're awesome too but we basically
sat down and said hey who are we how can
we understand what we want to be and how
can we create a brand both a visual
brand and a voice you know how we speak
brand and you know from that we got our
artwork we got these concentric circles
we got this framework for developing new
album art and then from that we also
knew well if we're this unique here we
have to be this unique in our music to
you know the ways we audibly present
ourselves yeah well it shows and also
the the design of the changelog calm
that everything kind of reinforces that
visual design that visual identity that
you all have established for yourself
and now I really want to learn more
about the website my understanding is
it's written an elixir it's snappy and
it just has really good clear user
experience like you know exactly what is
going to happen when you click on
different things and everything's pretty
clear it for me it's been a real
benchmark and and we've taken a lot of
inspiration from it with with freako
camp and in our recent our recent
efforts it at redesigning and
simplifying and things like that so
thank you yeah
who did most of the design like what's
the story behind yeah platform so it's a
everything's a team effort and I think
one thing that you might notice to this
conversation is that we do sweat the
details we have a few scenes that we use
internally one is slow down the move
faster we also say what's the ones that
slow slow and steady wins the race
yeah well that stuff about being slow
check yourself that's my favorite yeah
so yeah because we can get a we can get
moving - you can get out over our skis a
little bit yeah too often in anything
you feel like especially when there's
opportunity and you're ambitious
all too often did the opportunities
Trump your ability to say no right and
you next thing you know you're going in
places you don't really want to for
other reasons and it's like if you feel
pulled in anything you're doing beyond
your capacity just slow down and check
yourself alright so we said that's right
do the hand like that
it's yourself because if you have you
know some DNA and some guidelines so if
we know that we want to you know slow
down to move faster or retreat to attack
or to slow down or slow and steady wins
the race if we have those it's sort of
like underlying mantras to ourself well
anytime we get pushed beyond those yeah
so let uncheck yourself yeah and it's
worth reminding ourselves with these
things because we are in an industry
that moves so fast yeah and the pressure
is to I mean move fast and break things
is the unfortunate you know slogan of a
major player in our industry which we
don't like that same at all so slow down
and and move faster that way even when
you think about software development
practices right like thinking things
through
upfront is slower but you also move
faster in the long run setting up that
test harness right before you move on to
writing the code is slower but you all
you move faster in the long run I mean
people who are TV advocates they will
say the same thing like you think
through things first and you move a
little bit slower and it seems like
you're not getting that head of steam
but you know two weeks from now two
months from now two years from now
you're moving a lot faster and so like
the brand is an evidence of that as like
we took the time we slowed down spent
two days in a room and then many
beyond that you know that was like the
foundation of like building this system
in this design and then we can extend it
over time we can move faster on new
things we have all this stuff in place
mm-hm and so a lot of the website is a
result of those initial branding
discussions a lot of design is done
either by Jake or by Cody Peterson who
is a longtime contributor and really
colabor with us on the project he does a
lot of our front end a lot of our design
work and then add it on myself whether
it's giving feedback or cranking out the
code that renders the pages so I've done
a lot of the actual software work on
building the elixir app but everything
we do is team efforts mm-hmm
one interesting thing to note is is the
fact that Jared said earlier I was a
Perl guy then I was a ruby guy and so I
built the site in the liquor that this
doesn't equate but maybe you could sure
why yeah I mean so I've always like I've
always been a polyglot and I like
programming languages I like the go
program in language even though I don't
write it on daily basis I liked I like
look I like a lot of languages and so
I've never found one that didn't have
any redeemable qualities I even like
aspects of PHP even though it has point
less redeemable qualities in regard to
syntax than many others slight dig I
like PHP too we talk to a lot of people
about programming languages oh I mean
that's one of the things about our work
is we're exposed to everything in fact I
was just thinking about something that
came mainstream recently and I was like
we did a show on that three years ago
like not boasting but just like reality
like we are uncovering things before
they blow up in fact we have a
changelogs nightly one of our emails
that goes out every single night it's a
whole point is to it automatically just
gets the most start repos on github
before they blow up is the idea or like
right as they are and maybe those things
are going to go on to greatness maybe
they aren't we'll pick through them and
try to find the one that are interesting
and interesting yeah but it's an
indicator so we're just just because of
what we do and and and our show we're
just at the forefront and so we talk to
a lot of people about programming
languages
and some people assume therefore were
like deep into these things or we adopt
everything and it's like no I'm like 99%
of the stuff we hang up the call on a
Wednesday afternoon I'm like Adam I
gotta check this thing out because we
just spent 90 minutes with person who's
got something cool they created you know
and I'm excited because I get excited
about you know cool stuff Jam stack I
remember actually I think that was the
one where jam stacks be coming to be
like a mainstream top it you guys
rebuilt your stuff and gem stack we did
the show on gems 10 years ago at least
two and a half years ago and that's just
because I saw the Smashing Magazine I
mean they were the really the ones that
were for fine that laugh I we had the
Nano fight Iman we talked about Jam
stack and now it's becoming a thing that
but then there's other things that we
talk about and they don't become a thing
so that's just a fact of how the
industry works point is we don't like
then adopt all of the stuff that we
talked about that would be impossible
and ridiculous to do but there are
certain things that you know catch your
eye and almost nothing do I follow up on
because we move on to the next week or
the next show and we have other things
to do but elixir actually did catch my
eye and I tried it mhm and I fell in
love with it and I wanted to use it and
so that's why I was her it in the lick
sir and it extends from Ruby like it
takes yeah it takes a lot of them rated
by a prominent member and Ruby community
yeah and so it it looks Ruby ish when
you look at it but the more you get into
it yeah but it's not Ruby it's
interesting it's almost kind of like
there's this DNA that goes back to pearl
through Ruby and now do it like sir yeah
and the thing about the elixir
combination there is it's like a I
wouldn't call it a facade but it's more
like a carrot on a stick like it's like
it's like something that attracts you
and you're like ooh this is interesting
and then as you figure it out you're
like actually this isn't what I thought
it was but it's still very interesting
it's almost like I mean calling it
lipstick would be another bad analogy
but there's something to it where the
Ruby relationship is there because Joe's
a who created lick sir
knows Ruby inside out and he knows all
the best stuff and so when you see it it
almost looks like Ruby code but then
when you start to learn it you realize
oh this is something completely entire
different and yet I feel at home even
though I'm in a completely new paradigm
which is functional programming yeah
changelog dot-com of course is
open-source you've got a whole lot of
contributors not only contributing to
that platform itself but also
contributors who are hosting shows yeah
who are some of the key people within
the changelog somebody to name somebody
a name somebody we've mentioned a few by
name Kody Peterson is a key player on
the website with the brand with the
design work Jake was crucial to
developing the changelog brand
guidelines and the album art BMC we
talked about in great great depth
Gerhard you mentioned Gerhard is going
to coop Connor on our behalf he's been
working with us for a couple of years on
infrastructure really helping us roll
out since I guess when we first brought
the site on 2016 on the node yeah
exactly so I didn't really understand
how to roll out an elixir app in a way
that was old-school I'm very old-school
like associations of the box and like
you know run to start apache or nginx by
hand and that just uh isn't really the
smart way to do things that you can do
them better so gerhard has really helped
us pave the way of like doing smart ways
of rolling out our infrastructure over
the years and is gonna be representing
us at coupon which is very cool so
thanks to gerhard and then as you said
we have more than just our one show now
so we have a couple shows which are
panel shows and we would love the
variety there so Jas party which is all
about javascript in the web has nine
regular panelists myself being one of
them any particular episode has three or
four people on it sometimes it was a
guest so we just kind of like mix and
match really borrowing from the the
cheers model as I call it one of the
show Cheers yeah we just want to go
where everybody knows your name the idea
there is is that you're at a party or
you're at a meetings and go times the
same way by the way now you go to a
place where you want to hang out with
people and it's like it doesn't have to
be the exact same voices every single
time but there's like regulars and
there's that familiar voice and it's a
place to go where you're gonna get
riot II but you're also gonna get
familiarity just like Cheers and you go
to the bar and go back and watch the
show some episodes are out this person
something about that person and so
that's really the model that we came up
with for Jay s party which is like they
don't have to be the exact same hosts
every single time but you should have
regulars and so we have nine people who
kind of just like mix and match and then
we invite guests we could definitely
name each and every one of those yes I
don't even know them I mean I know the
names may yes I'm having my mother sues
Hinton for ossobucco DJ good job Kevin
ball goes by Kay ball NIC nice see who's
a fellow Omaha and is on the shoe boy
that's his tag line Chris Taylor
yep Christopher Hiller bone school he's
the the one of the maintainer of the
mocha Jas test library mm-hm
Divya Sasa Darin yep short dip on
Twitter she's awesome she's on the show
and we got to 9:00 yet myself M of it
again
I'm a vet again yep and I think that
rounds it out for now I was counting my
Rogers Michael Rogers yeah see I was
counting on my fingers but I wasn't
actually counting I was just doing the
riddle yeah yeah and so I lost count
Rachel white who hasn't been back but
she's trying to come back you know it's
been a while she's been on but I love
hearing from her as well she's got
awesome laughs I love her life and so
much fun - I'll try go times T's now I'm
gonna pray stop alone somebody's Matt
riotous love Matt John Calhoun Johnny
borsa Co Carmen and Oh Ashley McNamara
JBD that's six more dates more fates
that's the cast that's I think so if I'm
if I'm I might I think I feel like I'm
missing one do you say Johnny I did okay
should pull up the website well and
obviously the original cast can't forget
those guys car Lucia Pinto you got Brian
Kittleson you got over st. Maarten now
you know we started that show you know
three how many years ago
many years ago five - hmm maybe for 2016
we launched that show and you know we
learned a lot of things from from Diaz
party not to sort of explain why the
cast is different but just to sort of
like evolve that a bit we learned some
things about Diaz party in the fact that
like this whole cheers motto that
Garrity's just mentioned but it's it's
really nice to hear more than just a few
voices and then also sort of what I look
at is like representation of a community
you know so rather than just you know
one or two or three people that are
always on the show why not have a
rotating cast like we've learned from gs
party but but one layer past that is
like those are people that are out in
that community sort of bringing their
perspective to it and then even bringing
in content or different topics that the
three people are the two people or
whatever don't always see it sort of
gives you a larger more wider
perspective and then also this
opportunity of fresh voices more voices
or representation and that's why that
shows also evolved to sort of like
borrow and learn from a lot of what
Gia's party's gotten right it's also
worth pointing out as a podcast hack
that in addition to all those things
that we just described which are great
virtues of that format is that we want
to have great people on all of our shows
yeah and the thing about great people is
they're very busy and so it's very
difficult to get the same great people
week by week at the same time to show up
and do a show prepared and all the
things that are required to put together
a good show
so we've learned that because we started
those shows with less cat a smaller cast
and so one of the things we adjusted
it's worked out very well is like with
three great people it's hard to get all
three of those together all the time and
so scheduling is one of the major
challenges of podcasts another reason
for pod kick and pod fading with nine
people
we can get three people together out of
nine yeah and and it's less pressure on
us as panelists and even if they're
unprepared or not as well prepared as
they'd like to be it's not especially if
you've got a lot of gelling or cohesion
in the in the the folks involved it gets
a lot easier to sort of like throw show
together last minute if if it came down
to it right you know it's just a lot
more flexible - yeah and less pressure
on us as individuals so one of the
things
about the consistent info podcast is
let's face it you're just not excited to
do it every single week or you have a
conflict or that topic is not
necessarily something you're into or
that guess to somebody that's rubbed you
the wrong way or what if there's a
thousand different reasons and if you're
the only person that does the show well
you're gonna do that show yeah right but
if you have a cast of nine you know
somebody could take a month off and the
show goes on yeah and like we want the
shows to go on and so that's one of the
reasons that's the other reason why
we've moved to in those particular shows
a panel format also just to just spread
the burden because what would happen in
this in that case isn't just that they
couldn't show up it's that they would
feel guilty for not being able to write
and then that leads to a you know a
spiral of burden burnout guilt all these
things that sort of like plague us this
sort of self voice saying you should do
this or you should do that you should
you know all these things that make you
feel bad for not doing the things you
want to do because you have ambitions
you got a busy schedule or you got a new
job or whatever might be we like that
because somebody could be a panelist on
one of our shows and take a quarter
break you know like they've got a
teaching thing or a new job spun up or
they've got some travel planned no big
deal it gets a lot easier to collaborate
work with us because we're flexible you
know we're for like a better channel you
say family first is the easy way to say
that but yeah and you know when you both
have kids yeah right you can empathize
with life exactly a life period yeah I
mean you got a sick kid you got vacation
you got whatever you know gonna see
parents going on a family whatever it
might be we want to bake that in so
because I think what happens is you
start to form relationships to get very
rigid and very tested because you just
can't measure up every time you're not
excited about the topic you've got a
busy schedule whatever it might be if
you bake that flexibility into how
things work now that those shows in
particular work well now the change
levels Jared and I essentially talking
to somebody lives it several shows where
I can't show up or I'm busier or
whenever might be it
Jared takes over no problem or I'll take
a show by myself whatever
but it's different for those shows
that's not how we do those shows those
shows that are more community focus
shows need that one of these that
community representation but then also
that flexibility to enable people to say
yes and be a part of it yeah there's
something important there beyond
changelog with regard to sustainability
in your work because as you can tell we
care about this work a lot and it's
something that started as a hobby and
was a passion and we're so passionate
about the things that we're doing but we
do not want to create a thing that then
becomes our lives and defines us as
humans and we wouldn't want that for any
of our collaborators as well we live in
an industry and we serve an industry
that deals with burnout all the time
yeah in fact I got sick of talking about
I got burned out on talking about
burnout because I just could all of our
guests are people who are in this
circumstance and they're all having this
same terrible sort you know thing
happened to them and you know it's a
huge topic of conversation on our shows
and in our industry in general because
it's that thing that's happening on a
way too frequent basis and we want to be
in this for the long haul we we can't
allow ourselves to burn out by going
nonstop you know that's why this one was
slowed down to go faster right slow and
steady wins the weights we have to
remind ourselves that we it's okay to
move a little bit slower because we have
these other things you know and so we
try to maintain even though we have the
complete flexibly flex flexibility and
freedom to work all the hours or do what
everyone is like let's maintain a
consistent schedule and not burden
ourselves too much because that will
first of all burn us out but also it's
gonna reflect on to the people who
collaborate with us right and they're
not full timers right there they have
jobs they have open source projects
they're coming on our shows because this
is something they want to do yeah but
you know that that can create like Adam
said the guilt and the shame the shame
and think we don't we don't have
anything to do with that stuff so so
essentially through having just like a
really like a lot of redundancies the
word I'm I'm hearing uh-huh think you
have a lot of people who can step in if
somebody doesn't feel up for it or if
somebody needs to take a break just by
it's almost kind of like a big
distributed system kind of mess yeah
you've got like a pope subsystem right
you published and some
so that like they're like all right I'll
take this gig here right I'll be on this
podcast yeah I mean for instance coop
Conley so we would love to be a cook on
the timing doesn't make as much sense
Adams having a baby I've traveled a lot
this year one of the things we do is
we'll talk about conferences we limit
our travel because that's another aspect
like we love to go to conferences and be
in the community love it a lot but we
limit that ourselves because well every
time we go to a conference we're leaving
our family right okay so that's a
circumstance where like we want to
personally be at coop con but that's not
gonna work out and so we have Gerhard
who's over in London doesn't get to come
to the States as often it's gonna be in
San Diego he loved to have a trip to San
Diego and he's gonna be there and and so
that's a situation where it's like okay
that makes sense and we've just kind of
slowly you know built these
relationships with folks where it's a
win-win-win-win but it's also cool too
specifically what Gerhart is that it
gives us a chance to sort of like invite
him in further to the fold he's already
worked with us and done tons of amazing
things for us to help us with our
infrastructure but from a Content
perspective we've had him on the show
we've talked about change laws
infrastructure but nothing specific to
like giving him more opportunity so to
speak and so this was a chance for us to
say hey we can't make it there and
rather than being like oh we just won't
go or you know or us stretching our
limits and going and trying to go we've
linked well who would be better to go
for us and and also have other wins or
win the wind behind that behind the
thing so I mean I love the fact that one
guy was ready to go he's excited cuz I
see him behind the scenes and the emails
and stuff like that planning his trip
and he's fired up right and so a year
from now we may have a whole new thing
we're talking about because of these you
know the you know just like with the
drill sergeant this invitation to come
in
Gerhardt's already lead in other ways
it's not where everybody leadership it's
right it's the invitation into into the
family deeper you know more more things
and we think of it like a family really
I do and I know Jared as well
yeah that's great they give people
opportunities to just take on more and
more responsibilities and also just to
travel yeah yeah and and Trippi told
he'll speak much better about kubernetes
yeah just saying this is like on the
topic of conference just real quick you
all do go to a lot of conferences yeah
and and I'm glad to hear that you have
recognized that you don't want to go to
all the conference right because we
don't at all that we don't want yeah
yeah exactly
yeah and the same thing with me like I
just need to spend time with my family
too and in the travel time and
especially depending on where you're
going the jet lag yep as consequences as
well so what are some conferences that
you all try to make it to regularly or
what would you say yeah that's the first
question ask another question about
share and second so I would preface by
saying that our circumstances are unique
a similar to education where each person
is different so when it comes time to
like pick a conference go to a
conference you have to ask yourself what
are you trying to get out of the
conference like what are your goals and
that will inform which ones are a good
fit because there's so many shapes and
sizes for us it I line it up with the
changelog of the show which is broad and
polyglot and open source focused and
community focus and so we try to find
conferences that are along those lines
also because we only get to go to a
couple a year you know we kind of say
like maybe for a year once a quarter
makes sense we don't always hit that
fall times needs to be like there's lots
of conferences in the fall so we tend to
go a little bit more than is that we
tend to go a little bit bigger
conferences because we want to meet new
people right we want to see more
listeners or meet people that can become
listeners and so staples for us I mean
the staple for us has been oz Khan yeah
yeah we've gone done Riley's oz Khan the
last four years straight I think only
three yeah yeah since 2016 every year
yep so oz Khan's the big one it's always
a black on coop Khan we've been that
this will be our third year back and
then go for Khan go for Khan and all the
things that all things open and and oz
Khan and all things open have a lot in
common I would say yeah go go for cons
obviously a language oriented conference
so it's different than the other ones
yeah and then coop Khan is obviously
kubernetes and all the cloud natives
which is a big thing yeah but it's not
as like cross sweeping as as as the open
source focused one so those are the ones
that we always try to get to
none interactive - we've we've I've went
that one one time cable went there last
year and I think Nick's going there this
year so we this is our third time going
- it's changed to the name of it so I
think this year's iteration is just node
I don't know if it's known interactive
or not but it's always been just notice
known as node interactive but since
JavaScript and node and the GS
Foundation and jQuery foundation have
sort of like changed and merged just
stuff like that it's had some naming
changes - so awesome and my other
question regarding conferences would be
what would be your advice to somebody
out there who's listening who has been a
developer or is getting into software
development because you all know a lot
about different conferences there yeah
what would be a good first conference
and what would your advice be to them if
they wanted to attend one of those
conferences hmm so first I will small
plug we have an entire episode of J's
party called the conference scene mm-hmm
which we do we do an hour four of us
about this specific topic so go listen
to that if you want the long-winded
version sure a link to that yeah cool so
short winded and my advice would be pick
something a small single track the cool
thing about single track is that you
don't have any decisions to make because
the less you know the harder is to make
decisions what do I want to go you know
and there's the FOMO of like there's
three tracks which I might miss the good
thing a single track has a shared
experience everybody saw the exact same
thing and so it's a much easier to make
conversation
you know because you saw the exact same
talk that person did and you don't have
to say hey just hear what Chris coiour
said they're like no I was in the other
track okay yo we can't be friends right
so awkward yes a single track is great
for people just getting in like for your
first conference smaller-sized is great
because it's just less intimidating more
one-on-one opportunities so you know 200
people find two to five hundred versus
like a 5,000 person convention so 200 is
really tight
yeah 500 a little bit more loose but
still small enough mhm mm and then you
know other aspects is like regional is
fun because you don't the travel as far
so like it's less of a
the worst thing is like well I spent a
bunch of money I took three days off of
work and I travelled across the country
and I didn't have a good time right now
it's a little bit less risk if it's like
well I drove an hour and attended one so
I there's a community aspect to the
local conferences if you have a language
you like like if you're in a Java Script
then you're gonna find a JavaScript
conference in your local region that's a
great option that would be my advice
mine is very similar small conferences
are cool especially start I got fond
memories of actually a future of web
apps also known as fella
2010 man met some awesome people
Allen branch Stephen Bristol and several
other people and like they've they were
quintessential friends very influential
I've gotten some of the best advice in
my life from Stephen Bristol just
because we literally met at a conference
because we had a podcast called the web
2.0 show and they wanted to meet this
these two dudes behind this show that
didn't have a gigantic audience but just
enough just enough as all took and they
became great friends and for a while
there I was going to smaller conferences
like that like Lonestar Ruby conference
a couple different JavaScript conference
I think Gia's what was it Texas GS or
txt yes yes was was started here and
somebody else on just party sorry Texas
yes yeah Alex accident man yeah I'm
Sexton um just one more name for him but
the point is is just that I met some
amazing friends so like it maybe I was
fortunate that you know just that
conference I got to meet people at the
same conference I also got to meet Gary
Vaynerchuk and Kevin Rose we had a
podcast about with them at that
conference I happen to have lost my
voice at that conference so I sound like
DMX and Kevin said so which was pretty
cool too but Kevin Rose Gary Vaynerchuk
and a bunch of other fun people we've
Kathy Sierra who's like a an icon in
user experience just
I mean just amazing so I mean some
really cool people over the years that
you know it was a smaller conference
maybe 500 people but you know I got to
meet some really really good friends
personally so that's that's my personal
experience from it awesome one piece of
advice before you move on those are the
bytes on like which conferences to go to
but when you're at the conference so
nothing noteworthy ever happened when
you stayed inside your comfort zone
right you're not gonna come back home
and tell your significant other or your
friends some great story because you
went to a conference and your tenants
and talks and you didn't talk to anybody
and then you went to the hotel then you
flew home or whatever the logistics were
right listen I mean if you have to
actually push yourself outside of your
comfort zone and it's not gonna feel
good because that's what comfort zone
means right but this is your opportunity
to meet you know people face-to-face in
the flesh whether it's someone you look
up to somebody who is sitting by
themselves and need someone to talk to
like if you're going to go to the
conference like we can get virtual
conversations all day long we get them
and they aren't always that great as is
evidenced by the conversations that we
have online but in conferences face to
face you can have amazing conversations
with amazing people but not if you just
go and you're a Wallflower yeah and so
if you're going to go you're gonna put
in the effort and the money and all
these things you have to push yourself
outside your comfort zone otherwise
you're not gonna get out of it what you
can yeah I got one more extra on top of
that not just that but we learn from
Eric whole sure this thing called the
pac-man roll all right so if you're you
know I've never heard this okay I'll
give you the short version there's a
whole podcast about it will point back
to what add more links to the show notes
but Eric Holder was a big fan of
inviting people and including people and
if you're if you can imagine being at an
after-party or some or in the hallway
track whatever it might be and you got a
circle of people and there's no openings
you don't film funny to come in right
you don't get invited to come into that
space so if you leave that wedge there
that pac-man shape well there's room for
one or two more and as they and then
that circle just get bigger and bigger
but you always have that gap in there to
invite people in so he gave talks about
it he wrote a blog post about we had a
podcast about the talks and the blogs
and I just you know instead
you have a podcast about the pot that's
right that's right but the point is is
like you know if you're at a conference
describing Jerrod scenarios one more
layer to that is like always leave space
to invite one more into the ground if
you're staying in a circle look around
ya see if you can make more of a pacman
shape because that invites one more
person in yeah so that's a great tip
yeah I've heard like keeping your body
language open where you keep your feet
out yeah point your toes pointed out
that that also makes people feel more
welcome also just saying hi yeah hey how
are you that's a good tip yeah looking
at people with them yeah yeah well these
are they seem like obvious things but
they aren't easy and we've all been in
the awkward circumstance where like
you're approaching a circle and there's
no gap there and you're like do i wet
you know do I just hang out what until
they let me ease in right there's all
these awkwardness is it's already hard
enough to get out of your comfort zone
and like approach somebody who may
reject you or whatever the fears are but
when there's no like openness from the
group it's even harder anyways we're
right yeah I mean it takes me it took me
years to get comfortable just
approaching developers at a developer
conference and now when I go to some non
developer thing where you know nobody
knows anything about me or and I'm just
like some interloper all right then I
have to reapply all those strategies
again to like breaking the circles and
talk to people yeah it's hard every time
yeah it gets easier but it's never easy
yeah it's good practice though yeah
we're sure we're also in in many cases
distributed environments or very virtual
environment so the awkwardness is gonna
be there it's gonna be there so I guess
just own it embrace it embrace it yeah
speaking about speaking of embracing
things you know you all have embraced a
lot of change it's right there at the
beginning of the changelog that's right
name and you're heading into a new
decade a new era of the changelog and
you know it looks like the field is very
open and you've got a lot of possible
things you could do with the next 10
years
what are some wild a ambitions or areas
that you want to explore or charts you
know
courses that you've already charted that
you having in the headend that you could
share with us I'm usually more visionary
and have like some sort of cast but I
feel like we're doing what we need to be
doing right now
and for me that's okay because I think
we do a lot and you know I've got a
growing family and so personally right
now I feel like I'm a little
short-sighted on my vision I like what
we're doing I think there's a lot of
things we can improve on we mentioned
the fact that our code base is open
source every year we like to participate
in Oktoberfest we like to invite people
in to contribute there's always room for
more shows but we're also not trying to
grow our podcast count tremendously I
think over the next several years we
might grow by one maybe two shows a year
or basically as topics or interests you
know kind of come to come to fruition
I would I would like to to maybe do a
bit more on the membership side you know
invite people in in that way because
there's so many people to reach out and
say how can we help you how can we
support you and it all honestly the best
thing we can say right now is like if
you make a list a podcast if you're on
Twitter if you tell somebody about your
favorite things and we're one of those
things that's the best way but for some
people that's not enough right they
actually want for some reason to give
you money or some sort of exchange of
value and I think we gotta finally find
out if it's not just money or some other
ways we've got to find some way to
exchange value with our listeners beyond
us really giving our podcast to the
world
it's got to be something but they can
come in and do something of value
whether its monetary whether its
contribution to the codebase whether
it's something involving in the
community a lot of opportunity is also
on the written side we'd love to find
more people to share their big ideas
through our platform so there's a lot of
things I think in that area that would
make sense to expand more and growing by
more podcast isn't that interesting to
be right this very moment it's already
hard yeah so I think we have a good
portfolio I'm proud of it I think we
serve a lot of niches I wouldn't say
that we're your comprehensive like every
developer knee
there are there are a couple of holes
about if you if you if you pin me down I
could name a couple of holes in our
lineup but I think revisiting
memberships at this point makes sense
because of the kind of a see change in
the attitude toward memberships and I
think we can provide unique value to a
paid membership that we didn't provide
back then I think there are people who
would love to support us in that way
especially if they get some add-ons and
some maybe like a an ad-free option or
something like that create your own feed
like these kind of ideas or things that
were tinkering with where we could
revisit that and really serve more
directly I mean I love the idea of like
just directly serving your audience you
know every single time like the period
your day of that I don't think we would
ditch our current model because this
model works and sustainable we've proven
that out but we could augment and
provide options so that's something that
we're interested and I think personally
I agree with Adam that I'm not like
super stoked to add a bunch of new
podcasts maybe just focus on growing
vertically versus horizontally at this
point I in terms of my own interest I
would love to do more writing I've just
in the last six months or so maybe even
less been able to finally become
full-time on changelog and slowly wind
down my consulting company which was a
long burn but we're like basically down
there at the point so I can concentrate
fully on changelog I have lots of things
to say and and to write I just don't
have often the time to write them and so
I'd love to be able to execute on more
of those opportunities and use use our
writing as a way to really augment the
shows and like bring people back to the
shows yeah
let me see this too because you'd
mentioned earlier with when Jared came
on to the team you know while you were
speaking one thing I was thinking to the
negative to describe Jer would be
instrumental all right like if it
weren't for you we didn't even talk
about me going full-time ever in this
cut in this conversation which is this
need to go that far but the point was
was that Jer was a source of
encouragement for me he was like I was
working at pure charity
and so just a quick version of the story
and this is basically me giving Jared a
long thank you is that an appreciation
too because he's an amazing partner
and I couldn't do this alone that this
would not be what it is if it was Adam
solo
it just wouldn't and I'm so thankful for
Jared but ages ago he was like dude we
can do this you could do this you could
do this whatever I forget the exact
wording but but I've always been an
entrepreneur but I wasn't like yeah I
want to quit my job that's cushy because
I was working for a non-profit it was
amazing work I love what we're doing I
love the team we're building I love what
I was building I loved what I was doing
and then one day I just love this a
little bit more and I was like you know
what you're right and then if for me a
silent partner for me at least not a
contributor to a show but a huge
contribute to my life as my wife if it
weren't for her yeah I work for Jared
encouraging me and saying you should do
this we can do this and for my wife to
agree and believe in me I would have
done it honestly so thank you bro
honey welcome and I'm glad that you made
that leap because you know a few years
later it's allowing me to make that leap
I was already out there on my own at
that point and so there was like I
didn't have that I mean we all know that
resistance yeah of like when are you are
you going to or do i or don't I or when
do I
and so I already had the confidence was
like you know I'm out here swimming in
the water and everything's fine you know
the waters warm out yeah yeah and I was
in that water and I was like I like that
one or two but now I've got this warm
water and I just was less also you know
newly married so it was just like timing
but I still have mad respect for pure
charity the team that runs that I mean I
still consider them all friends they do
amazing things as a matter of fact a
community member
Beverly Nelson she's done some stuff
with it's been a while she's been really
busy but she is CTO CTO at pure charity
she began I don't want to say just as a
developer in a negative way but she kind
of came in when we had a budding team
she came and was very instrumental and I
don't think then you know she would have
believed that she would have been CTO at
some point now she's CTO of pure charity
that's awesome yeah and we love Beverly
she's amazing yeah well it sounds like
you all have a lot of people who have
been on the periphery
directly involved we can change log over
the past 10 years huh and I want to wish
you all a fun prosperous next 10 years
to the life of the Chinese log I'm going
to be listening I know that a lot of the
people in the freako camp community
learn about open source and learn about
software development in general and get
introduced to a lot of the people whom
you've interviewed you know DHH Yehuda
Katz on a while back just a ton of
really like developers developers mm-hmm
and they're able to get a lot of
exposure to those people and a lot of
inspiration for those people so I just
want to thank you again for everything
you're doing for the community and you
know long live the changelog 1000
there's 10 more years of awesome
learning that's right let's you think
you've always been a staple for us to
you've always encouraged us and
congratulated us along along the way to
we're obviously huge fans of free code
camp we can't say it enough and you know
just thank you for caring enough about
us for one to drive from your place to
my place here in Houston we are in for
lack of better terms
Adams studio yeah you know so he came
here we flew jared invited by a cherry I
mean this is your that's right what well
almost call it like you know cheese long
HQ but it's not but you know we really
appreciate you know the time that you've
put into this to the research and just
sharing sharing your community with ours
honestly I really really appreciate that
we can't think enough all right well hey
Adam Jared it's been an absolute blast
everyone still with us thank you again
for listening to the free cooking up
podcast be sure to check the show nuts
where we'll have links to a lot of the
different episodes of the changelog that
we mentioned here and and some of the
articles as well also if you've not
subscribed to the changelog be sure to
subscribe to it the free code camp
podcast will come back in early 2020
we're just as I said doing a lot of
other things but in the meantime if you
can just tell your friends about the
changelog tell your friends about free
coke amp that would mean the world to us
have a fun day and happy coding
four years ago four years ago we talked
to you and since then you have literally
blown up in many good ways now if he
literally blew up wouldn't he have
exploded and has guts Hornet okay
figuratively Jared's always my I always
do that yeah although technically you're
right literally you can mean the exact
top right well depends with dictionary
right in this case blown up meaning that
let's start over again guys I was
digging that flow are you were yeah I
will keep it then we'll keep it
Jared likes will keep it but but
seriously four years ago we had a
conversation with you much different
free code camp today then four years ago
what are you doing that's so great what
are you doing is so well that has gotten
you to where you're at not just you but
the rest of everyone the contributors
pretty skeptical or not I mean we tend
to be at time skeptic or paid to be yeah
we're paying the be skeptical well
there's lots of stuff that comes out and
some writings last I think we're talking
about that earlier and the other show by
the way kind of a companion podcast
going on right here so definitely listen
to the other one as well
links will be cross posted it's right
show notes check them out I mentioned
there lots of stuff hits our radar and
some things last and other things don't
and I know one of the things we were
talking about then really four years ago
now links in the show notes to the
original Quincy Larson episode of Hall
DS by the way it's been four years the
first two gets you back it should have
been much faster yeah we have the B
backs back sooner you're still here
you've blown up you did not fail to
sustain so I thought you agreed you blew
up I do okay good yeah well I think the
difference stuff I'm guessing is that
then was just one pillar right now you
got many more Pinocchio things that
happened what does that work yeah so
2014 almost exactly five years ago we
launched just the curriculum itself we
had a chat room yeah so people come in a
frico camp and they've worked through
the curriculum and they would ask
questions in a chatroom which was
originally HipChat and then it was slack
and then it was get er we still use get
her but now the main thing is the forum
so the curriculum was the the original
pillar of freako camp and now we have a
second pillar which is the forum
is growing really rapidly and we've got
a lot of exciting things going on there
that I could talk about and then the
third pillar is the publication free
code camp that org slash news you find
it interesting that that forums are cool
again
there always are cool ish I mean to some
degree sure like another quintessential
community of the Internet to a certain
degree yes but then you have social
networks and you got groups within those
networks that's like true you know what
is truly a forum so you're saying in
this case a literal forum yeah a self
hosted place where people can have
threaded discussions right over long
periods of time that's indexed by Google
that has its own search tools that has
accounts that has moderator tools all
those things where the organization
who's hosting that forum has control
complete control yeah if you contrast
this with like you know a subreddit or
if you contrast this with a Facebook
group a forum gives a lot more
organization a lot more power to the
organization it also means that you know
the data stays on that server yeah with
that organization it's not being used
for advertising curious how you host it
what do you do yeah yeah so we use
discourse which is a really popular form
tool yeah created by Jeff Atwood and is
is a partner of Sam I can't remember Sam
is less than 7 Sam Safran thank you and
they are really solid developers and
they also know a lot about online
communities you know Stack Overflow
being one of the bigger ones so a lot of
the same defaults that they bring to the
table or are what we use so yeah what
about literal hosting though like do you
host it yourself
what do you mature which architecture w
a Sarah yeah so it's it's a docker image
and we just we have it on digital ocean
Oh gotcha
so we use a lot we published this whole
organization like visualization of free
code camps architecture and this course
supports our instance so don't feel like
that 80 bucks a month I say go for us to
have a hosted digital ocean I was asked
not because this course does have like
us like a service version right yes so
you're not hosted by the immune history
room but they still support
got a support well in the sense that
like we every six months that there's
some huge thing I start messing more on
their own metaphors
yeah like hey yeah yeah yeah and we have
SSH access but if there's something
catastrophic we you know we can ask them
to go click flip the switches right so
the buck doesn't stop at you in terms of
the you host it but you got help
well freako camp the forum is one of the
bigger ones I think there are probably
some bigger like I know blizzard and
describe bagel so we're getting about
five million views a month on the forum
nice and big
I assume that's a lot of recurring
active you I mean there's lots of
conversations yeah forum hit some people
are just googling they find a solution
in a forum but there's a lot of people
are actually like actively part of the
community posting answers posting
questions on the daily yeah at any given
time there might be 60 80 100 people
logged in using the forum so let me go
back and Club tackle uptick I let me go
back and clarify the skepticism because
I wasn't that we were skeptic goal of
the concept or the idea free code camp
it was really just like the will it
continue to last because you're a
non-profit there's lots of startups that
are also nonprofits they're just they
don't want to be nonprofits but they are
but we talked about the sustainability
of like you pouring yourself into this
we didn't know it was pretty new at the
time all you had was curriculum and it
was like is this gonna be around right
that's not a time into and it seemed
like a lot of work and anytime you see
those those things that's just addressed
before maybe yeah for burnout yeah or
goat farming in the horizon right but
you're still here you're still standing
so I guess that's maybe the question is
is Denys thriving fair enough
striving what if you found what's
working what how did you get to this
point you know you have a probably a
team you have lots of I know you have
lots of people you know so would you
figure out that way yeah well last time
I was on YouTube were both asking lots
of very silly questions about
sustainability because as we do yeah and
and you since you've had the whole
request for commits series which is
phenomenal I recommend everybody check
it out and I listened to that and Nadia
egg ball and Michael Rogers
you know that was really helpful for me
as well just thinking about open source
and sustainability and since I visited
we finally got the 501 C 3 status which
is the US government's tax-exempt status
code it's the same one that like Doctors
Without Borders and the Red Cross and
all these big NGOs have right so now if
you donate the freako camp you can
deduct it from your taxes and we
ourselves don't have to pay taxes which
is a huge savings Lily yeah and it makes
a big difference so we were able to
shift from just selling merchandise
which was the only way we were
sustaining freako camp which you know
spoiler alert it was barely covering
even the servers let alone you know
payroll and other things and I put a lot
of my savings into it I put about
$150,000 into freako camp which keep in
mind I was a teacher in a school
director that's like I was basically
saving her half of everything I earned
for like 10 years yeah that was the
money that I had we were gonna use that
to get a house and or a down payment on
a house in California but then keep you
up at nights like we're used we were you
confident you were gonna find that that
thing that works over there nights where
you're like you know what I'm just
wasting my savings away well so I wasn't
I never thought it was wasted because
people were benefitting tremendously but
I was worried that it was not gonna work
out and I was gonna have to go get a job
but really that's like that's a very
nice first world problem to have like oh
my gosh if this fails then like yeah
nice job as a software engineer right
but I mean 10 years of your savings gone
is beyond that what are you saying is
that that isn't outweigh the risk of
loss and I guess to some degree the
belief in what you were doing enough to
keep going what you've done
yeah yeah I have a nice though oh that
kind of risk that kind of that kind of
any fear anything like were you really
twitching oh yeah it was a long and I
had my first child about here in I guess
deeper so you know that was and we were
living in a we were living in the Bay
Area in a one-bedroom apartment yeah I
was like seven
square feet and we had a baby in there
and I was just on my laptop all day long
everyday just crunching trying to
reassure my wife that we would pull
through and everything would be okay now
she had a job at a tech company doing
accounting and she as a result we had
health insurance so our position was
already better than a lot of Americans
and we both had lots of options so I
just want to emphasize that like we were
coming from a position of great
flexibility and privilege yeah that a
lot of people do not enjoy so I don't
want to sound like at all because really
I mean worst-case scenario I I had like
standing offers from different companies
that would have probably hired me and
all those things but freak ok was doing
great people were using it people loved
it and I knew that we could make it work
where there's use there's usefulness
yeah so what what financially made it
work finally like it's working now right
yeah yeah we're breakeven essentially so
what we did was as soon as it became
clear that we were gonna get our
tax-exempt status not that we actually
got it quite yet but before that we had
always been just shifting if you want to
support free cooking up here donate
money instead to women new code or
donate money to hack club or donate
money to hacker dojo or some of these
other nonprofits that are helping in
developer education because we really
wanted to make sure that people are able
to deduct things and the money was going
to an to a proper nonprofit so once we
got that nonprofit status
you know retro actively all all the
donations to us were tax deductible and
I remember just holding my newborn son
and holding up the hey the certification
that I got from the US government and
that was kind of the light at the end of
the tunnel and from there we've just
worked really hard to get a whole lot of
people doing monthly recurring donations
to us which is beneficial not only
because a lot of people can afford you
know five twenty even twenty five
dollars we had a few people give them
like two hundred fifty dollars a month a
lot of people can afford that and it
says it's monthly it gives us the
ability to project out
and for an organization like us like we
just need to be able to budget we're not
trying to make huge fixed cost
investments yeah we're just paying for
servers we're paying for people to be
working on free cocaine full-time so I
throw a number at you here this comes
from your five years of free code camp
post which is on change dog news also in
the show notes for those who missed it
more than 40,000 free code camp
graduates are now working in tech at
companies like Apple Google Microsoft
Amazon and Spotify
surely many other companies as well
that's an astronomical number 40,000
those are people who've been certified
through the program many of them have
gotten certifications that includes
everybody who's in our LinkedIn alumni
network which is like 60,000 ish people
who are working now in technical roles
not everybody ultimately got the
certification because if you get a job
like you're graduating the graduation
certification it would be a end to him
or a means to an end once you're at the
end you're not like well I really need
my FCC certification right yeah I don't
a lot of people get the job then they'll
come back and try to finish it what's
that
not that US you see what yeah this is
audio and this is the airwaves the
internet airwaves
that's right yeah okay so but still me
40,000 people that is to me a huge
amount I mean what does that feel like
do you feel those numbers and they get
so big at a certain point that it's kind
of like another drop in the bucket
I mean some what some numbers are hard
to actually like I don't know like reify
in your mind well I'm you know extremely
blessed and and I just feel incredibly
grateful that there are so many people
out there who bother you know emailing
me you're tweeting at me or sharing
these stories of their transitions from
you know working and counting being a
trucker working in manufacturing all
these different fields that they've gone
from to doing software development and
yeah so that's interesting it
contextualizes those numbers when you're
getting practically every day I get an
email from somebody saying hey I just
was able to do this you
thanks again and then I'm gonna follow
up and say like oh yeah can you tell me
a little bit more about how you how you
made this transition where can you post
it on the forum because a whole lot of
people are in the process of trying to
make it yeah yeah and so the number
isn't abstract I mean its abstract that
it's that large but I have so many
concrete examples of that every day they
drive home to me and so for me you know
it's just is it it's a dream come true I
never would have imagined that we would
have anywhere near the scale of people
being able to accomplishing things and
you know provide for their families in
new ways and actualize themselves and be
creative in new ways so yeah it's just
been a huge honor and a huge blessing so
one of the challenges that we've seen
people facing coming out of
non-traditional education backgrounds
such as I have a free code camp
certification or some sort other boot
camp or I'm self-taught is that that
hiring process is difficult for them for
lots of reasons one of the reasons is
that companies and organizations aren't
always on board with hiring I mean more
people are looking for senior developers
than junior developers and people who go
in through free code camp sounds like
they're having success getting hired do
you help them on that side of things or
is there like a community support I'm
wondering like if there's like tips and
tricks or how are people having that
level of success is like yeah I got
through the program and I got a job
because like you said the job is what
most of us are after and so I'm just
curious if there's like if the community
helps on the job side or if it just like
once you're through the program you just
are competent enough to get yourself a
job yeah there's a great question we've
kind of made a like a neutrality set up
where we don't we don't specifically
guide people to specific companies we
try we we thought about we built out of
a job board and we were gonna have it to
where people could apply for jobs
directly for through freak Ocampo we
just thought about like you know if
somebody has a negative experience or if
they're people out there who are you
know that you read about a lot of these
Silicon Valley companies that basically
just pretend that they've got all this
VC funding and things like that and then
the finally never materializing these
people have moved to this expensive city
and basically get stiffed on their on
their paycheck you know we didn't want
to be associated with any sort of like
project like that so we just decided you
know we're not gonna we're gonna leave
the job board stuff and the recruitment
stuff to the experts and we're just
going to focus on training people now we
do have interview preparation section
that has hundreds of additional
algorithm challenges we've got like
we've updated a lot of the project Euler
problems rosetta code problems and made
them interactive with like tests that
you can run right in the browser instead
of having to you know the old interface
for project whether was it's like a 20
year old website but it's just like you
enter a number and it tells you whether
you're right or wrong it doesn't give
you any more feedback than that and it
just takes a long time to enter it so
rather than having to do all that coding
locally and then go and type a number
into a webform and see if you're right
we we just modernized it made it an
interactive experience but so we've got
lots of interview preparation stuff
we've also got at this point probably
hundreds of I got a job type posts on
the forum and we've got lots of articles
from people who transition successfully
from other fields into tech who
successfully got jobs at Amazon or
Google or other places like that telling
how they went through that process like
especially the thing that people
underestimate the most is just the sheer
numbers game that the modern job the
modern developer java application
process constitutes it is quite often
for like somebody who's finished
freaking up or somebody who's gone to a
boot camp to have to apply to hundreds
of jobs and then they'll start to get
interviews and and then they'll start to
get offers but we just try to instill in
people the notion that this is hard okay
this is not easy anybody who tells you
it's easy to go out and get a developer
job they're probably trying to sell you
something because it's not easy that's
right so we have all these resources and
we have a supportive
who's there to share and your
accomplishments and you can just read
lots of you anecdotes that realize the
statistics that we all know that there
are a tremendous number of developer
jobs at all different levels certainly
there are a lot of middle tier and and
senior jobs and the senior ones are the
ones where the recruiters most actively
go out and aggressively try to recruit
people but there are definitely tons of
small a medium level businesses that
just need some but you know the church
or the local food bank or the other
organizations that want to have a nice
website or just need somebody to help
set up like a Facebook group or
configure like a Wix website or
something like that
from your vantage point can you see
trends there in terms of it getting it
right no means is it easy but are we is
it trending up in terms of those entry
level opportunities in your opinion or
is it just kind of been like a steady
churn obviously this would be from your
vantage point not like it's like based
on numbers but so I could look at the
numbers and we do have quite a bit of
data that we've made public we for the
last three years we didn't do it this
year just because we'd already done so
many times and there was already so much
data it's a lot of work we did what's
called the new coder survey and it shows
like how many you know it s about 50
questions we have like 30,000
respondents this is a really nice huge
data set yeah significant from a
statistical standpoint and if you dig
into that you can see like how many
months of experience people had before
they you know started applying for jobs
or how long they've been working in for
jobs and you can you know sort of play
with the numbers and figure that out
I don't have like a really well-informed
answer on that a lot of what I hear is
just at the street level people like
saying that they got a job or people
saying they haven't gotten a job yet in
reality is messy and every employer is
different every country is different too
they you know European and I say
European that's really like a collection
that we're on city-states right and then
you know you go to India you go to China
you go to all these other countries
where free cooking is really big and
and the markets completely different
I've been to startups in like Shanghai
where I walk in the room and half the
people working in the developer bullpen
or freako camp grads Wow right so so
there are definitely jobs out there for
people it's just a question of what
those jobs look like and how many
applications you have to make and how
many people are competing for the same
jobs I will say this though
getting a job I think a lot of people
think it's all about your skills but
it's really about three things in my
opinion it's about your skills it's
about your reputation and it's about
your network whom you know if you know
the right people
you can get in even with subpar skills
subpar reputation if you have a great
reputation you may not be the best
developer but people know who you are
from your blog post or from your YouTube
channel for your podcast or just from
your open source projects that you've
contributed to everyone would say point
to de-risk a choice right and the Ray
you dear iske choices by some sort of
assurance or certainty and so if you
have a decent reputation I can kind of
bet that you're a decent person
yeah de-risking is exactly what I think
employers are trying to do their share
they're just trying not to make the
catastrophic choice that results in them
having to terminate somebody yeah pay a
bunch of severance and then go through
the entire job all over again
yeah and it's it's costly it's that who
you know comes so it makes sense but we
try to be in the world where it's not
about who you know because it's almost
seems unfair and yet it totally still is
the facts of right right that's what I
mean like so if you don't know the right
kind of people you can't build your
reputation properly or at least it may
be add to an area where you have less of
reputation you have somebody about you
for your back for lack of better terms
if you have a network it's a network of
people to some degree associating with
you they're they're fun they're there
for adding the reputation that you're
trustworthy that you're right somebody
worth betting on or taking a risk on
yeah and this is why I like the local
markets are so important yeah people
focus so much on Silicon Valley and like
the hyper competitive like trying to get
a job
offer from Google Facebook or Amazon but
if you go to a lot of communities like
we're here in Houston alright and I live
in I live in the Dallas metropolitan
area and Jared lives up in Omaha like
these are all completely different
technical systems with different
employers different hiring cultures
different circles of people that meet
together for tech talks and events and
different professional groups I mean
like if you learn your local meta and if
you're content to stay in the city
you're you are and currently there won't
necessarily be like a clear roadmap for
you to get to that job but if you pound
the pavement and if you get to meet
people I think that things will work out
for you because you're already doing a
lot more work than most Java plus like
you said uh many companies that aren't
traditional software companies need
software people and so as you know the
old saying goes software see in the
world every company's becoming a
software company well there's a lot more
competition to work at the software
company right any developers because
they develop software for a living but a
lot of companies that just need like one
or two people and maybe their bar is a
little bit lower the competition is
gonna be less maybe you have a friend
who works there like there's just lots
of those well you make concern on
traditional software opportunities or
it's like well may they're not a
software company but they have software
needs and I bet you can pitch in there
maybe even more so than you could at the
place that has 100 developers already
yeah if if getting a developer job is
hard does that mean that it's got
something broken in the system and if if
you say yes what is that and if no then
it won't so if it's hard to get a job
that way what's it's somewhat of an
indicator that there's a broken system
yeah I know there's broken processes
something's broken what makes it so
difficult
aside from reputation Network skill it's
it's hard here in the US again and I
have lots of friends in China and India
and places like that where I think it's
comparatively easy not in every city in
those countries but in a lot of markets
it's just much easier to go ahead and
get a job in the u.s. we have like a
combination
like benefits like the legal framework
and all these things make hiring and
firing very difficult so because it's
it's difficult to bring some it's costly
to make a mistake yeah really
so that makes employers really
risk-averse even in a field where
there's so much demand and also
employers to some extent are operating
under pattern recognition so they're
like oh this person has worked at this
company right that's like the biggest
indicator of your likelihood of success
whom have you worked for and do they
have similarly stringent hiring
requirements so if you've worked at
Google there's a very good chance that
you're going to be a good employee at
you know XYZ Corp as well so I and these
are things that I think that there's a
great she writes a lot of articles for
free copious publication as well
alien learner she does interviewing dot
IO and she's written a ton of articles
that are much more data-driven on this
but I I wouldn't say hiring is broken
that's kind of a strong word but I would
say there are very clear ways in which
things can be improved without having to
completely overhaul you know the way
that we handle labor in the United
States for example just para programming
or doing more take-home assignments
rather than doing white board challenges
would be one I think for any obvious
improvement cuz that is heavily biased
toward recent college graduates who just
spent a whole bunch of time but
basically going ad nauseam through
algorithms for like tests and stuff like
that it doesn't work as well when you're
hiring somebody who's this who's been
out of the job market for a while if
they just had a kid or somebody who has
just been working for a long time but
hasn't interviewed for jobs recently
your mission isn't to get people hired
it's to educate would you say that would
you agree with that or is it kind of
part buslines so our position you know
you don't really help place so you're
not it's sort of part of it's an it's
implied by your efforts so our official
mission is just to help as many people
as possible learn to code yes I think
that's written at the bottom of every
single page in our footer that's our
official NGOs mission yeah that's it
virtually everybody who uses free code
camp
dreams of one day becoming more
technical now whether that's actually
being a software engineer yeah or just
you know being a designer who can code
or a marketer who can code or somebody
who wants to build like a cool interface
for their drone that they're flying
around as a hobby
yeah somebody who wants to build an
Alexa app just to impress their kids you
know there are so many different use
cases for programming knowledge but it's
all a net positive I like to say that
you know back in the 1600s you didn't
need to be able to read to go out and
work right but the people who did sit
down and take the time to learn to read
were infinitely not infinitely but they
were dramatically better off well same
thing in the 1920s if you learned how to
drive a car suddenly you had all these
new opportunities open to you and more
recently like the 1990s people really
learn how to use spreadsheets they learn
how to use word processors they learn
how to use like the slide based tools
like PowerPoint and that opened up so
many opportunities for people so yeah
you can get by without it you could be
you know a congress person a congress
person in 2019 who doesn't know how to
type and just relies on the secretary to
do the typing for them right but real
life like you are better off just
gathering those additional skills and I
think that soon people awaken to the
fact that being able to code is very
helpful and it does give you a whole lot
of additional options so figuring out
the financials is one aspect of
sustainability another aspect is making
it so that Quincy doesn't have to do all
the work and surely you have a team at
this point and lots of people
contributing so like to hear the
different roles who's involved in the
and then as a follow-up to that how you
inspired them to get involved in the
free code camps mission absolutely yeah
so freako camp currently we have a lot
of active contributors and I'm extremely
grateful for all of them and we're
getting ready to maybe by the time this
episode goes live we'll have our top
contributors for 2019
we've got some really nice backpacks
that we're gonna ship to them nice to
recognize their efforts to say 2019 Top
Contributor it's got that freako camp
logo and and these are the same
backpacks that we sold a few months ago
we're actually running a second run of
those two since we're gonna be printing
some these topic turbulence but there
are seven people who work for free code
camp full-time including myself and they
are all generalists in the sense that
they all wear a lot of hats
everybody comes up through free code
camp as contributors after a few years
of contributing if they seem to be
particularly capable or particularly
passionate then and we have the
resources then we will bring them on and
so currently the team is again me doing
just everything like I do support and I
also do I'm overseeing a couple
different projects within then we have
Bo Karns who is running the freako camp
YouTube channel which recently became I
think the biggest programming channel on
YouTube he's got one point four million
subscribers now there's a channel called
the new Boston that hasn't been updated
like four or five years and they have
more subscribers than we do but other
than them I think we're the biggest so
Bo runs that he creates a lot of the
videos he does a lot of the editing for
our contributors and Bo also is working
with a curriculum so Bo worked as a
teacher for I think five or six years
prior to joining freako camp a public
school teacher up in Michigan we have a
B Abigail Rena Meyer she is based in
Portland and she worked as a
archaeologist before she has like a
totally different background but she had
been editing thousands of articles for
the freako camp publication and she kept
doing it and I was like hey you want to
do this full-time so she's been doing
that she also runs the podcast so if
you've listened to the freako camp I
a good chance you've heard her
interviewing people and then we have
Ahmed Abdul Sahab he's in Turkey it
recently immigrated the turkey and he is
doing some exciting things over there he
does a lot of the design like when we
overhauled freako camps visual design he
did a lot of that work and he also does
a lot of just like the day the in and
out code maintenance then we have Rakesh
Mohapatra who is in Bengaluru or
Bangalore and he does pretty much
everything regarding the core code base
and like all the servers and he he's the
person we call if something catastrophic
happens and then we have Christopher
Koichi gawa who's in South Korea and he
was working as a teacher for the last
six years and started contributing a
whole lot to our to our interview prep
section and so we brought him on so he
and Bo are working together on the
updated curriculum which I can talk
about in a minute and then we also have
Mia Luo who is based in Hong Jo in China
and she's running the free code camp
chana team and we basically have like a
completely parallel organization in
China and we've got Chinese language
forum Chinese language publication and
Chinese language curriculum and that's
you know hundreds of thousands of people
using that so I think I got everybody it
is hard to always remember everywhere on
the spot yeah as we experienced recently
as well so that's amazing you have a
parallel organization in China just
curious in terms of the free code camp
alum or even just the users I mean your
team is spread abroad and so it where's
your biggest audience like would you
have the foothold in Lydia is it India
India and the United States are like
neck and neck sometimes India gets there
are more people in India sometimes there
are more people in the US and then
Nigeria is third and China
and then there's that based on just
visits or how do you how do you use you
know its load in use
yeah like Tom on site yeah all right I'm
so yeah Chinese translation do you have
translation into other languages as well
or just sooo yeah this is a great
question what we're trying to do is just
really make sure that we have everything
rock-solid in Chinese and Chinese is
bigger than most of the other world
languages combined its second only to
English if you look like Wikipedia usage
and this is what we used for our metrics
I like to plan internationalization we
looked at how Wikipedia was being used
and and and we looked at like the world
language usage for different
translations of Wikipedia and then we
looked at like the total number of
speakers of those languages that we're
using the internet actively china is
just exploding in terms of people
adopting technology and they're very
enthusiastic about it and a lot of them
are getting great jobs and there's a lot
of money going into just a lot of
different aspects of like artificial
intelligence like machine learning
essentially yeah they're the real
machine learning and also the ifs and
then statements and stuff like that and
then also there is a lot of expertise in
China India a lot of the great Indian
engineers stay here and a lot of the
Chinese engineers go back to China and
create companies so you know I'm trying
to think of some some names of famous
engineers who've left like Google or
have left like teaching at Stanford who
come back to China but there are a lot
of really promising companies over there
so we wanted to do China first I
personally maybe am alot of bias because
I lived in China for like five years
my wife Chinese and I'm just very
optimistic about the future of China
they've over the course of the past
thirty years they've taken hundreds of
millions of people from subsistence or
agriculture and they've transformed into
a manufacturing center of the world and
now they're transforming into
much more services in creative based
economy and learning the code is gonna
be a big part of that for sure you speak
to the the need for native language
curriculum like specifically with what
I've heard Lee is with China is that
there's you know this desire obviously a
massive amount of people there but most
of the documentation a lot of the books
tend to be or more likely to be in
English can you speak to the the need
for native language curriculum
yeah well it's always easiest to learn
in your native language is one last
thing you need to worry about a lot of
people more than a billion have Chinese
is their there may no more than a
million yeah yeah I mean if you include
if you include like written Chinese like
there a lot of write spoken dialect on
earth six point five seven billion
people a year behind like seven a half
or eight and so my yeah it'll be a toss
up into this that's that's machine here
okay but the point is is that that's
quite a lot of people I mean we're all
big Peter no that's a massive amount of
people that's like if they want to have
Facebook but I can't five that's crazy
yeah what makes sense to it it's
interesting to to hear your insights on
the choice to use a massive global site
like Wikipedia as an example to say a
smart you know why did you choose where
did you choose first under what
circumstances because in a lot of ways
what you're doing is creating a
Wikipedia for like a better terms for
software developers writing a curriculum
is very much like that wikipedia has
been a huge influence on us and of
course Wikipedia sure he's mostly open
source as well and they're also a
non-profit so right in many ways if
Wikipedia hadn't proved out the concept
that you could have a donor supported
Commons of learning material in their
case more encyclopedic in our case more
procedural skill focused learning you
know freako camp probably we wouldn't
have attempted it because we needed that
proof of concept I'm not the kind of
person who's gonna throw their entire
livelihood behind like a totally
well guess but I sensed I guess
correctly in retrospect that there would
be demand there and that people would be
people who were graduating from freako
camp and going out giving these great
jobs would turn around and donate back
to the organization and it would be
sustainable
do you see somebody utilizing free code
camp and maybe a boot camp as well or
some sort of intensive Azura saracen
area where it's only free code camp I
know you're not trying to do that
because you're very community-minded and
oriented but is that is the intention to
be freako Campbell loners it's sort of
like a companion to other learning
opportunities so I've always viewed
freako camp is a core curriculum if you
will and a lot of coding boot camps do
you use free code camp as either part of
their curriculum or they'll use it as
their pre coursework and we have a
really good relationship with a lot of
coding boot camps and I'm very excited
about the future of coding boot camps
really anything that can drive down the
cost of adult education
yeah University Zuri the hardest part
about that too is is curriculum
development yeah right like if you have
to start from scratch every time you
want to start up another boot camp
opportunity in your neck of the woods
whether it's here in the States or
elsewhere abroad you know if you can
string that time from you know desire to
teach to teaching it's a leg up one on
opportunity oh yeah I agree it's the
hardest part but it's not the most
important part the most important part
is the interpersonal relationships that
you know a teacher professor has with
their students and that students have
with one another and you know the
counselors that help you prepare for the
job search and all the other things that
a university or coding boot camp or any
sort of adult education program can add
like the value-added the curriculum
itself really if you think about it very
few people actually design curriculum
since that most universities have
textbooks yeah right and like everybody
like you go to econ 101 and everybody
has you know the same textbook
regardless which university you're
setting at for the most part okay so
yeah freako camp can be a free
interactive textbook that these
organizations can use and of course it
can be used on its own just like I could
go to a library and crack open the
textbook in and learn economics or I can
learn you know
program and see just from a textbook or
from some sort of static resource the
the main advantage with free code camp
of course is it's experiential its
project focused and things stick a lot
better when you're actually building how
do you keep it fresh how do you keep it
relevant current and maybe the naysayers
saying oh your curriculum is not current
enough or it doesn't is not idiomatic
enough yeah how do you how do you push
back the haters basically well we just
focus on fundamentals we're not going to
be covering leading-edge tools for the
most part like I believe that everybody
needs to just get a really strong
foundation first and most of what
constitutes foundational knowledge as a
developer stuff that was figured out in
like the 60s and 70s and in the case of
mathematics sometimes hundreds of years
ago thousands of years ago right so what
we're teaching is just the most
ubiquitous tools that are most generally
applicable
I think nodejs is to a large extent one
kind of the webserver war if you will
and javascript is useful for pretty much
any kind of load development we're
getting ready to introduce Python as
well as a core part of the curriculum so
currently it's six certifications each
certification requires you to build five
projects and get all their tests passing
so we're adding four additional Python
focused certifications so right now our
certification just for people who aren't
aware front-end specific we have the
responsive web does responsive web
design we have JavaScript algorithms and
data structures then we have front-end
libraries data visualization with like
d3.js primarily and then we have the the
full stack focused ones which are api's
and micro services and information
security and quality assurance so we're
going to add four additional Python ones
that will be either at the end of that
or will be we'll kind of break up those
but we're adding we're adding scientific
computing with Python we're adding data
analysis we're adding Information
Security with Python and we are adding
machine learning using tensorflow care
and potentially scikit-learn so we're
adding lots of tools but these are not
tools that are like groundbreaking Li
new these are things that academics and
practitioners in the field have been
using for years what about things like
the small things like I think of the
JavaScript syntax and the updates to the
language I mean the nice thing about web
development is mostly additive like new
technologies add on top of HTML and on
top of CSS with trends in JavaScript I
think the big change between callbacks
to promises to async await like those
are things that do get outdated do you
just like churn it out and keep it
updated or do you not fight those
battles what do you do there so we just
update like if if one thing like for
example CSS variables
we're probably gonna rip out our sass
section at this point because CSS is
getting so many of the core features
that like those pre-processors all that
and they're taking sass out yeah it's
about time I told you yeah and like we
saw the bootstrap section but probably
just gonna teach flexbox and grid and
stuff like that so so we do go through
an update and like like you just asked
specifically as new features are added
to es6 or es2015 them in c2 and add
additional lessons if necessary the
entire curriculum is about to become
completely project oriented this is
something we started at the beginning of
the year we're rewriting our lessons to
all be building projects so instead of
Lauren JavaScript and here are 200
JavaScript lessons that are tangentially
related we go through them it's learn
JavaScript by building a role-playing
game yeah nice and so you build like a
role-playing game you learn basic
JavaScript from that you'll learn
typography from building a USDA
nutrition label you know you'll you'll
learn all these different good about
things through projects and currently
the curriculum is like 30 certification
projects and all into lessons soon it'll
be 30 certification projects and
also a whole bunch of practice projects
like 30 or 40 practice projects so those
will all be interactive with tests the
entire time and you'll build the
projects one line at a time one passing
test at a time it's so much easier to
learn when you have some sort of like
concrete expectation or visual in mind
you know like giving somebody a goal and
not just abstract thoughts of like oh
here's you know as you said 200
different tangential lessons on
JavaScript it's more like here's what
we're learning in order to build
something like this that you've seen the
real world you maybe even used in real
world you know nutrition labels for
example what was that one for that was
tables learning typography typography
yeah yeah like visual hierarchy yeah
that makes sense yeah so we've got I
mean this is all of course open source
it's only github so if you want to see
exactly how our curriculum is coming
along you can check it out and we're
gonna keep plugging away at it like I
said Chris Christopher Koishi gawa and
Buckhorn's are working on this basically
full-time doing instructional design
they're both trained classroom teachers
who've also learned web development on
their own through free coking up over
the years and through other resources so
should be really really solid and even
if it's not totally solid when it
launches that's the great thing about
open source it'll gradually accrue a
whole bunch of improvements and
eventually it will be great eventually
great it's like eventual consistency
only exactly greatness
so in addition to the Refresh to the
curriculum you also launched a brand new
refresh to the learning platform you're
now buzzword compliant because you're on
the jam stack yeah you want talk about
some of the new infra and the code and
what you're doing there yeah absolutely
so jam stack javascript api is and
markup is what james TechStars things
for my friend Matt Dillman over it net
laughs I coined that term in a bar at
some point I don't remember the exact
story but he he's been a big proponent
of just like the security and the
performance boost that you can get from
you know doing everything at Build time
and then just serving like the static
files essentially right so now free coke
if you go to free cooking org and you go
in to learn app pretty much everything
is prepackaged and you get the entire
application it just loads and it'll work
offline
it won't work offline perfectly right
now but we're working on getting it to
be like a offline first app so there are
a lot of advantages and a lot of those
advantages have to do with the fact that
we don't have to sorry that little thing
threw me off text message okay yeah a
lot of those advantages just have to do
with the fact that we don't spend as
much money on servers yeah we can cache
everything I've been like a substantial
difference between like I mean it's been
like 5,000 bucks a month on servers what
do you spend now that you're on Jam I
think we're spending like four thousand
we're still doing a lot of the
optimizations I mean month gradually
it'll reduce yeah yeah yeah Wow eventual
greatness eventual greatness curious why
you know if you have such a massive
global audience why and this is just the
the partnership personality and me comes
out as like why you wouldn't reach out
to someone in that business to establish
some sort of partnership and make that
zero or very low if anybody is listening
who's like in a position to grant a
whole lot of credits yeah or take them
yeah we'll take them we use all that we
can get from like Amazon as your Google
Cloud like we use all their credits we
can get we just need a lot are you uh
picky on platform as long as it's
reliable so okay asher is where a lot of
our stuff is hosted digital oceans where
some of us hosted we we have to be very
mindful about what services we look at
we're like how critical that are so far
as your and my experience has been
incredibly reliable and AWS is really
reliable too but we decided to like
locate most of our database and our
servers in the azure because they gave
the most generous credits candidly give
it they give every nonprofit like 3500
for
thousand dollars a year in credits and
that that's a big big head start
and so we locate everything in the same
data center and reduces latency so if we
had like a significant offer of credits
we might be able to relocate the entire
stack for like learn over to a different
place but we'd want to we wouldn't want
to do a piecemeal just because the
introduction of latency and additional
security risks and stuff like that but
either way with the new stack you've
definitely been able to shrink set
budget so yeah and this is just they
want like this is the very beginning of
their stacks I mean another point of jam
stack is you do it when you well you
said most of your stack is we still have
like servers that like are these like
things that are like api's yeah yeah
yeah so whatever you eat it whenever you
complete to ham a lesson for example it
writes back and if it can't establish
connection with server just stores in
like local memory or I think local
storage is what we use and then when it
reads died was a connection than it
pushes so we're building on all that
kind of you know we're done see and
turgid miss right very cool so any
drawbacks on the jam stack so far like
things like oh we didn't see this one
coming cache invalidation is always
challenging like you push a bunch of
changes and they're cached on CloudFlare
netwo Phi's CDN or something in you just
have to wait till it propagates or hey
try refreshing and we're working on
figuring out a way to do that so we
don't have to tell people try doing a
hard refresh web developers least
favorite phrase yes try refreshing that
we hate saying things like I can turn it
off and on again right it's kinda like
that yeah I kind of fail at the cache
invalidation part Oh hardly fresh teach
people how to heart refresh versus
regular refresh yeah I've been there
yeah than that so that's that's been the
biggest drawback but I mean a hole and
then like like I think Nell if I was
like under like a DDoS attack the other
day and like we we had some some uptime
issues with that but again it's like
they're doing the best they can they're
pretty small organization compared to
like the AWS is of the world uh-huh
we just want to be there to support them
and we're just grateful that like you
know nullified discourse a whole lot of
other organizations have given us in
kind
sponsorship and this is they're not
giving us money but they are giving it a
service in services that makes a big
difference yeah
so the third pillar of what you're up to
have talked about the learning platform
the forum's we touched on at the very
beginning of the conversation we haven't
talked much about the publication yeah
yeah that's a big part of freako campus
we have free cocaine federal work slash
news and we have hundreds of authors who
are publishing articles there every week
not not like actively we don't get
hundreds of articles every week we're
going for quality over quantity it's not
an open publishing platform or you can
just like sign in and start publishing
with with the publication you have to
apply and we're really selective I think
like we had 5% selectivity so most
people they'll submit a whole bunch of
writing samples will force them to read
our style guide and all that stuff make
them jump through all the hoops if they
want it badly enough then we'll give
them a conditional account we can
contributor account and then they can
write drafts and we can look at those
and if the the moment we see one of the
drafts that were like yeah this is ready
to go this is solid we can do a little
bit of editing publish it and then we
give them full access to our Google
Analytics so they can see exactly who's
reading their articles like basically
everything Google Analytics tracks and
we've got a bunch of additional custom
filters and stuff here really simple for
them that's the only tracking we use by
the way we use Google Analytics because
at this point it's the only server-side
analytics are great but you just don't
have enough information for the authors
to be able to understand their
readership as this process of
collaboration or lack thereof if there
isn't any on the Edit process how do you
handle that do you have sort of baked in
processes where you're giving them
feedback and suggesting edits or do you
make the edits and say this is how it is
how does that how's that relationship we
make the edits for them and then we tell
them what that is we made generally if
usually that it sort of our seemingly
unimportant but actually really
important like the headline is by far
the most important thing to the point
that I'm practically on the phone was
just like I was just gonna write the
headlines for you yeah like that's all
ninety percent of people see especially
in the age of like Apple news and reddit
and all these aggregators
people just scroll through headlines and
that's their news like very few people
actually click through do you actually
say anything like a headline is this a
suggestion from them and it is let's say
for like a bit of terms it's some it's
in your hands at the end yeah what they
write may actually become the headline
but it's actually just a suggestion yeah
we're clear that like essentially
they're they're writing and to save a
whole bunch of back and forth a bunch of
communication overhead that slows things
down we just apply the edits ourselves
yeah and people understand that they
appreciate it because they understand
that we care a lot about quality and we
want to get their article read by as
many people as possible the way we do
that of course is after they they
publish it we publicize it through our
Twitter account which I don't know how
many followers it has a lot is it like
it has a high level of engagement let's
let's say that like generally when we
tweet something it gets retweeted like
10 to sometimes 100 times and we also
have a huge LinkedIn alumni network and
we get like 2 million impressions a
month just off LinkedIn posting things
on LinkedIn so and then of course I have
my email blasts I send out and I've got
like a mailing list of like 2.5 million
people so a lot of people click through
and read those articles that I choose
for the weekly email blasts so it's
worth it
we're giving them a megaphone to reach a
whole lot of people and to really raise
their profile in the developer community
and they take that opportunity seriously
yeah what kind of pieces are you looking
forward because I know I remember in
your post you mentioned like
journalistic kind of stuff eventually or
I don't know eventually we'd like to
have explanatory journalism where we
take like net neutrality for example I
wrote maybe like 10,000 words about net
neutrality and I put everything in
context right during the peak of like
people asking about net neutrality in
curious about it and it was it put it in
a historic context with all the other
mediums and appreciated it the other
media that preceded it like radio cable
stuff like that and so that would be
kind of like the archetype of like if I
was going to lead by example I'd say we
should be writing in-depth articles like
this and there are plenty of other
publication
is that right real like New York Times
The Wall Street Journal a lot of them
will just have really in-depth articles
that put things in a historical context
it's not just like this happened and
this happened this happened it's like
this happened and here's why that's
significant from a historical
perspective or here's what that means
so explanatory technology journalism
explanatory technology journalism that's
that's kind of our aspiring goal one of
our goals is to get people to actually
come to freak Ocampo org every day and
have something new and exciting that
they can learn right now people just
blow through the curriculum and they get
a job and they're like awesome free
cookie I use that back in 2017 I hear
that all the time yeah about that
because it's one thing to you know if
your mission is to educate as a primary
mission and you mention the three
pillars it's gonna be very difficult to
keep a captive audience because what you
just said so it's very easy for people
to be transient given that their goals
and their means have been covered and
they're gone yeah so you know it makes
sense
I almost want to ask you like you got
curriculum you got the forum and you
have publication you know how much
thought that you put into that because
it's pretty smart because you're you're
answering my question without even
answering it by by this publication
being there and free cooking up news
being there because you're bringing them
back whereas before they don't have a
reason to come back and now they do and
you're sort of keeping them captive when
yeah when before they were just you know
they've learned they've gotten their job
they've moved on and they've said hey I
learned about it back in and that's it
now yeah and there's always more stuff
to learn right right like I learned a
lot about quantum computing in the past
few weeks I learned a lot about you know
microns length semiconductor
manufacturing and stuff like that
right so there's always new stuff that's
coming out I mean technology by
definition is new so there's always new
stuff and just being able to explain how
you know you orchestrate with kubernetes
or how a docker container works what's
the difference between a docker image
and you know a docker container
right or a docker instance like can you
remember all the different terms
you need an article do you have you've
mentioned a free code camp mission but
do you it seems like the roles of these
pillars are distinct so do they have
their own agenda that feeds into a sort
of main or corporate agenda like why
these three yeah yeah so we are strong
believers in content I think that one of
the biggest tragedies is that so much of
the rewards of the web have been accrued
by platforms that are basically just
aggregating other people's content if
you look at like Facebook and right on
all these companies they're benefiting
from providing the basic infrastructure
you could argue that you know medium
fits that boat kora they just create the
software everybody else comes in as the
content and people don't care about the
infrastructure that much they really are
there for that content right it's if you
like you saying like Netflix you to crew
100% of the value because they created
such a great streaming platform and that
like the Hollywood movie companies
shouldn't get anything because hey they
just created the content contrary right
right cheap but content is it content is
not a commodity really good con and
content is incredibly valuable and if
you look like there's the information
for example it's like this news
publication that charges like hundreds
of dollars a year to get a subscription
The Economist historically is always
charged like 150 200 dollars a year
alright first subscription and I think
we're going to see more and more of
these publications that are like this is
really high quality so we're not gonna
give it away for free at the same time
there are publications that do give it
away for free
yeah I Pro Publica and you know the
Guardian in place like that and that's
because they're fully donor supported
they can do that and free coking of
course being fully donor supported by
you know small individual donors we're a
grassroots organization we can do that
we can make everything free and we can
provide tons of content from our
community and from ourselves like like
paid staffers like me who are writing
articles and things like that
yeah so let's talk about donations real
quick and they won't switch gear so they
do want to talk about meetup you
mentioned platforms there yeah so five
bucks a month let's just say I'd go and
sign up for recurring I'm and I like
your mission and I got the cash I'm
gonna give you five bucks a month where
does that
go yeah great question so first we've
got seven people okay first let me talk
big numbers so so everybody understands
freako camps 2019 budget was three
hundred seventy three thousand dollars
that may sound like a lot of money but I
know developers in Silicon Valley who
personally make more money than that a
year sure that is maybe payroll for like
three or four people right and and we're
figuring out a way to like stretch it
across seven people and we're also
paying you know tens of thousands of
dollars a year in servers so the answer
is like 100 percent of that gets
consumed by the by what is traditionally
called programs when you analyze a
non-profit there's a fundraising there's
administration and there's programs and
we don't really have donation we don't
do fundraising we just that we have
Quincy Larson saying please donate to
our nonprofit please sir you know right
we don't have a PR firm we don't have a
marketing department you could argue
that we could do better and we could
raise more money that introduced a lot
of complexity the organization and right
now everybody who works at freako camp
came up through free kokia right never
go out yeah I get it and I would say
like I know a lot of nonprofits that do
the fundraising side and of course it's
it's akin to like a bootstrap company
and getting VC funding I mean there's
like some analogs there but it's
different but you could at lead
I mean but the small the hardest way is
the individual recurring donations
versus having a person on staff maybe
it's you or maybe it's somebody who's
really good at going around to the big
donors yeah
maybe that's the reason why well part of
it is is responding my point is you
could get like a 1 million dollar grant
maybe yeah
but as we hold into those organizations
and also like that would kind of spoil
us that's why going and fighting in the
field to like earn people's donations
regular people people who are just
working day jobs have kids and feed and
paying mortgages but they're like hey
yeah I can spare five bucks for free
coke amp a month or yeah it's the end of
the year and I could just give them a
thousand bucks for ten thousand bucks
well what about those companies though
they're reaping the benefits
of your work that's fine it's like a you
know a positive externality for them
right its consumer surplus from them but
there's
uncaptured opportunity there I mean you
could argue the same thing with
Wikipedia I mean how much value do you
think Wikipedia has bestowed upon the
world by making it to where I can get
good factual information within seconds
from a relatively objective arbiter of
truth
yeah there's a whole lot of value that
is not captured but that's that's kind
of the point yeah but then they also
have to put Jimmy Wales face on
Wikipedia for like one month every year
and bug the dog-doo out of their users
when they could just do these other
things such as some tasteful ads you
know no you know no there's no wrong
with advertising I think it's a great
model especially for podcasts but but
also you know like if you if you don't
have the invasive ad networks and stuff
I think I think yeah I think we're
advertising could be a I think one oh
you decided to go pretty much ad free
across the board I think it's a
admirable decision that being said we're
back I cut you off on the donations
thing like used to pretty much that
whole five bucks is going right towards
programs yes and there's no fluff
there's no like there's nothing else
it's all right there
we were now removing relevant lean I
mean we we did we have in-depth
discussions about whether to like pay
for like a $20 a month service because
it's like overly yeah yeah I mean things
are we just want to operate really
efficiently like a lot of my heroes like
you know Sam Walton for example kind of
Walmart on this notion of thrift and you
can argue that like Walmart has not been
the best employer the best patron of
different communities that it's been in
but you it's hard to argue that it
hasn't been good for the end consumer
because they've managed to drive down
the prices so many things absolutely and
save people an incredible amount of
money like especially families these are
corporations that could probably make a
lot more money but they're choosing to
kind of be broader and more resilient to
changes in the economy and things like
that yeah it's a trade-off yeah it's a
trade-off well with freako camp we're
never gonna capture all the value we
don't even we're if we can capture like
just to give you an idea less than 0.1%
I
I'm sorry it's it's about 0.5% of our
monthly active users donate yeah so it's
just a fraction if I can get a little
bit better matching all right we're
going to my next question and so let's
talk about scale how do you what are the
conversations you have with yourself
yeah or anyone else in the team about
like okay if when you said your budget
was three hundred seventy-five thousand
a year
yes 78704 this year this year this year
373 sorry 373 so is that it is that
equate to revenue and I guess the second
question might be you know when you talk
about growth of revenue or income
dollars how are you describe it in our
profit census what are the ways in which
you made that number grow yeah so we
just get more people using freako campus
as simple as that
the more people that use freako camp a
certain percentage of them will go out
and get great job around a donate like
sometimes we hit you know like a
windfall like I was saying earlier we
had somebody who donated ten thousand
dollars this month
Shawn Wang Xuan Wang he's a he went
through a frico camp he works at net
laugh I and he had money at the end of
the year and he wanted it done into a
high-impact charity free code camp just
to put our efficiency our capital
efficiency in perspective we have
delivered 1.1 billion minutes of
instruction this year that's the
equivalent of 2,000 years of learning in
one year we've done that for three
hundred seventy three thousand dollars
that's the equivalent of 50 hours of
instruction for every dollar spent and
now you're putting in terms I like to
hear so if you go to lose my five bucks
feel a lot bigger yeah so your five
bucks each month is essentially paying
for an entire classroom of people to
learn that's interesting I like the fact
to that I lost my fun that I'm getting
just a second
well I lost it all right I'll get it
back in just a second yeah one thing
that is important to note also is that
these people are able to do it for free
and the scale that we're operating at
you know it's not only self-paced and
free and fully interactive it's just
incredibly cheap like to put that 50
hours per dollar in perspective in the
United States the average cost of having
a child in a public school
is $10 per hour per child so free code
camp is several orders of magnitude more
efficient yeah then like and graded
they're trying to accomplish totally
different things we don't have a
classrooms we don't have a teacher with
a student-teacher ratio of like 17 to 1
or whatever we just do instructional
design and people work through it at
their own pace but it's because of those
concerted decisions that we're able to
be dramatically more write efficient
these are all conscious decisions we've
made because our ultimate goal is scale
our ultimate goal is helping as many
people as possible for as little money
is absolutely necessary
what's brings you back to what I forgot
I like the fact that you focus on those
two metrics you grow the number of
freako camp you know I guess interested
people users how if you want to describe
it and then that obviously impacts the
ratio of donors and you can sort of like
grow that one to grow this one or you
can grow this one too I mean like
meaning you know if you grew the amount
from 5% 5% I says that yeah okay a
percent geez if you if you double that
if you double to one percent right I
mean so you can sort of focus on those
two metrics either grow the total
captive audience or grow vision you know
the ratio of donors that's I like the
simplicity of focusing on two things
rather than so many other things yes to
grow to scale yeah and that's why I'm
reluctant bringing in like you know a
fundraising expert or all right you know
to
a court like personally fly around and
meet with the CEOs of all these
different if you can get by without it
it's obviously better you not have to do
that and it seems like you're on that
path do you have these two numbers the
higher leverage one is honestly the
percentage yeah but you seem to be
pretty good at growing the top and
funnel at this point yeah all these
people using it you've been very patient
so based on four years ago we talked to
you and you're also and I don't use a
word too loosely but you're not greedy
right like there are some people that
just and maybe it's I don't know really
how you describe greed where it's not
egregious or something like where it's
all really great yeah you know like
right you know you can have capitalistic
ambitions and not be greedy you know you
seem to have a patience that is uncanny
well I for that I where it's not not
everybody has the kind of patient you
have like I don't I don't I couldn't do
what you've done you know I I managed
you know for profit companies before I
started freaking out like is the school
director essentially like it was a
private intensive English program and no
I had to make sure that we had like a
good day and you know all those metrics
that matter so and I have kind of a
traditional business background and in
addition to my education background so I
can understand the physics of business
so to speak uh-huh and that's really
helpful because that gives me some
perspective and it's kind of like if
you're a jazz musician if you don't know
how to play you can just do chromatic
scale play whatever it doesn't sound
good but if you do know how to play you
know exactly how to break the rules and
how to bend the rules to make it sound
really cool okay so that's like to some
extent defected I'm older I'm you know
I'm gonna turn 40 next year that gives
me a huge edge because I've got the like
the life experience I run a lot of
organizations before free code camp so I
knew like the people part of it and
imaginary part of it so I guess in some
respects one of the reasons I'm more
patient is I'm more confident in the
state of the world and how things work
and fit together and also you know I had
my wife who has the page
of job and she had a job with benefits
and and we had health insurance for our
kid and for ourselves
yeah and so I didn't need to you know
run out and buy that Ferrari or whatever
is that you know startup people do when
they when they exit like freako camp
will hopefully go on forever and
hopefully hopefully at least for the
rest of my life which I'm hoping to live
to be you know ninety a hundred like
hopefully I can continue to be involved
in leading or helping somebody else lead
the organization for the rest of my life
so everything is long-term this is not a
problem that's going to magically solve
itself you look at how long it's taken
to get people to you know to even get
literacy to the rate it is yeah after
four hundred years right now this is
gonna be an ongoing challenge to teach
people about technology we probably had
people coming into developer land at a
faster rate than the birth rate at this
point just a thought a thought exercise
think it's true which ones actually you
don't have any faster so I think maybe
converting more developers then we're
burning them at this point so huge
massive forward-looking opportunity as
well and impact so let's do a hard cut
to a - one question before we do our cut
yes real fat I don't think it'll take
you long to answer this one it's
probably really easy even for you have
have you gotten offers or people venture
capital anybody that that's come to you
and said quincy i will buy what you got
i would get you know whatever servi have
you got some like how often do you get
i'm not going to say the names but we've
had some big companies that like I've
approached us if for like equi hire I
guess I don't know how it would work I
mean this is before we got the tax
exempt status but once we got that
people just left us alone because it you
can in theory unwind an NGO like if
somebody wanted to acquire the Red Cross
and be like this bureaucratic nightmare
and really thin so much time I'm sure it
is possible Bert yeah but that's never
gonna happen here and I'm grateful that
you know the those organizations saw
value in free code camp but that's not
where we're like we don't want to be you
know free code camp fire
Acme corporation yeah or something like
that right I just would imagine the
offers are a plentiful and the
temptation is as is very I mean learn
it's not really for me would be I mean
for some depends yeah I'm just a simple
dude like I like hanging out with my
kids I like reading books and going
fronts you know I mean I don't know
because I'm in this very fortunate
position where I live in a really
advanced country with rule of law and
order like you get more money it's
almost like an insurance policy right
like if I get cancer I'll be able to pay
for all my chemotherapy and my
radiotherapy or any surgeries necessary
right if my kids get cancer I'll be able
to pay for that so money at some point
like just becomes a score a number that
in theory you can dip into if you really
need to I don't think that that really
applies to me I'd much rather just be a
normal person and have a normal kind of
middle-class middle American life and
then be cruising around in a Ferrari in
San Francisco or something yeah our left
good okay hard left here and so closing
in closing we're gonna talk about this
topic because you're not busy enough a
free code camp you decide you know what
we want to do we want disrupt we want to
disrupt meet up with an open source
event planning platform for not just for
developers but for everybody to be able
to just set up their own instance with a
docker container tell us about yeah a
chapter and why you're doing this and
how it relates to at least relates to
the current and so the recent changes in
medium I'm not sure if it was actually
inspired by that if you're already
working on and you're like oh this is
opportunistic tell us the story of
chapter real quick yeah so meetup was
acquired by we work a couple years ago
we work as we all know was not worth as
much as they said it was pretty
disastrous reversal reverse I do yeah
yeah it's it's one for the history books
but anyway we work of course and as of
October when I made this announcement it
was a few hours after meet up in
announce that
enacting this new policy that they were
going to charge everybody a $2.00 RSVP
fee whenever they RSVP'd for an event
now free coke amp writing Lee as 40-ish
meet ups on meet up most of our study
groups are organized on Facebook because
free but some meetups will pay the $20 a
month to have a meetup page which i
think is ridiculous that it cost that
much money but it does and people are
willing to pay for it so we quickly did
some back of the envelope calculations
and based on the number of events we had
it would cost us like twenty thousand
dollars extra every year not just to us
but to the entire community in aggregate
if they were all paying that's too much
says essentially yours to potentially
get us a donation so just yeah there's
money in their pocket that they
shouldn't have to spend RSVP is not a
veteran the organizer it's yeah people
who is from meetup right for the
platform the infrastructure that hasn't
changed the only notable thing that
meetup has done in the past ten years
was get acquired by we work they have
been a web site in terms of product in
my humble opinion and I say this is
somebody who's been using me to play and
I could say that as well because there's
like I recently as part of this was like
I thought I closed my account i
double-checked my I didn't know they
closed it because I thought I did before
I think when they were required by we
were it was just like I never knew they
got acquired I just this was the first I
had heard I mean I just been on
yeah grudging meetup use her as well
just more from me they've done some
other stuff too I can't recall what it
was like you know what I you know if I'm
if it wasn't like oh I'm canceling you
know meetup from my life it was more
like I don't use the platform anymore I
don't find value in it and I'm like wow
I finally if you leave a profile
somewhere at least your data is still
there so there's still this opportunity
for them to use you when you've since
mom gone away so my thought was like I'm
gonna pull my account and not do that
anymore
well what I love about the open source
community is like we don't have to put
up with that stuff if we don't want to
that being said somebody has to step up
and like throw some code on the table or
a speck on the table yeah you know
that's one of the things
with siege bots about what they're doing
with the federated you know replacement
for the package management it's a call
to camera the name of it all sudden
entropic yeah and drop the topic yeah
you know and just the fact that it's
like well we could all sit around and
complain and hey as people who talk in
the microphones a lot some of the
someone that we do is just thing for us
to do is to complain yeah we complain
quite a bit but in the open source world
it's like hey we can actually solve some
of these problems and that's why I was
just impressed by the announcement and
you guys at least beginnings of an
effort to say you know what meetup has
value these this is the thing that needs
to exist but it's not like it's a
replicable or replaceable so it's so
yeah we quickly made an announcement
like I thought about it really hard I
just decided yes this is important
enough this is going to make a big
enough difference for just us that it
was worth having self-hosted chapter
management tool I mean that's what it is
is for multi chapter organizations so
we're not trying to boil the ocean and
just say we're all events every word
just like meetup is right we're just
focused on like you know if the YMCA or
the Boys and Girls Club of America or
Rotary Club Lions Club some of these
other organizations that have lots of
chapters they can just have their own
server they can have full control of the
data and people can go there and set up
events and and they can have chapter
organizers and then they can have some
discovery within their own organization
and they can just have a little sub
domain or subdirectory it's like you
know YMCA dot-com / chapter or women who
code org slash chapter or something like
that right so as far as how it's coming
on long I tweeted up this kind of
somewhat angry tweet by Quincy Larson
relatively emotionless sweet standards
and a lot of people were like yeah
that's messed up you know like it was
like it I think it was a tweet of the
screenshot of like the meetup there are
as many cheerful announcement oh great
news the words everybody right yeah this
is actually gonna slightly reduce your
cost as an organizer and past like
massive costs on to the community but
anyway a lot of people retweet it and I
had a little link to a discord room
which this Court is not open source of
course but it is
convenient for organizing an impromptu
thing I've never had coupons and stuff
so everybody jumped in there and we got
like a thousand people jump in most of
them just of course promptly left and
forgot about it but some of them stayed
and we started brainstorming like what
kind of tools are we gonna use what's
the user story you know what are they
gonna look like who are the rolls and we
quickly got a lot of stuff ironed out
like at the schema got like an API
documentation uh got an API up so now
we're just building a lot of the
additional functionality we need for our
MVP but soon it'll be up and of course
it won't be amazing right off the bat
but eventually it'll be great I love
this of course it won't be amazing
there's a theme it eventually to be
great that's right I like the theme for
the show eventual greatness so how do
people get involved I mean typical
github flow like hah yeah fine chapter
and the show notes and like get involved
because there's a thing that we could
all could use and if you could use it
and you want to have seems like to me
pretty easy entry low-hanging like
collaborator fruit like hey here's a
pretty open project that's still getting
itself figured out that's the best time
to get involved because like huge impact
like you can be you can be a big
contributor early on
check out chapter from the free code
camp crew yeah is it would you say it's
a meetup alternative though well I have
a question if the answer is yeah then I
mean it's for our purposes yeah as a as
an NGO that has lots of chapters around
the world absolutely like we're not
gonna use meetup anyways you're solving
your own problems at first and hopefully
this the problem you have is is
multiplied by many others yeah yeah sure
it is
but even if only we used it internally
it so be it's just fine twenty thousand
dollars in savings and also the pride of
us being able to go in and tweak things
and not having all of our user data just
be like owned by we work they're
desperate you know cash squeezing
efforts so what about more traditional
meetups so like we have the Nebraska
JavaScript end up it's just a very
typical JavaScript meetup is chapter its
not multi chapter it's just like well we
do it mean it over and you can run like
a ye you can run your own instance just
twenty bucks for what
over five bucks to get it like a tiny
little server that'll run it yeah we're
trying to like make it as compact as
possible like instead of using elastic
search for example we're just gonna use
pulse grass queries so little tweaks
like that that just reduce the number of
services we have to have running in it
in a docker container yeah how's the
idea of federated ever yeah made it into
the into it and how did that go on that
sure I mean not necessarily from a
technological perspective but just like
a way that you can opt into being part
of a shared Discovery Network right
exactly right because the main benefit
of Meetup yes really discovery yes right
that's the that's the only yeah I mean
if you if you have your own organization
you already have a mailing list of tons
of people your people know your website
and they're visiting it already then you
don't need to worry as much about
discovery but it's it's still the nice
thing yeah but you still go there and
check your interests to know if a new
group comes up near you geographically
let's say my interests are JavaScript
and Ruby well anytime anything touches
those two areas then I'm gonna get
notified so it you wouldn't want to just
prop up your tent without an audience
and no opportunity for discovery yeah
yeah you wouldn't care about federal I
mean this could eventually come to a
displace meet up and a lot of respect
for that's not our goal at this point
even though initially I was like so
angry at mean opposing yeah let's let's
just create a mean of killer but that's
not how I think like when I'm thinking
clear headed Lee and I don't see red um
I think I think practically what can we
do for our organization what can we do
for our community and this is the right
scope right scale tool all right it's
gonna work for them it's been five years
for since we last time five since the
inception this is your fifth year
anniversary similar question in the
companion podcast you asked us which was
hey what's the next five years like for
you what what's the future hold for you
or you lack a visionary like I am
currently or are you visionary and
you've got lots of ambition I have an
incredible amount of things I'd like to
do a lot of it comes down to how much we
have in our budget because we don't want
to overextend ourselves we're a tiny
organization we want to make sure
everything we do we do prop
and then we're not spreading ourselves
too thin so if we can continue to grow
our budget we'd like to do a lot more
explanatory journalism and explain a lot
more about technology and put tech news
in context through really in-depth
primers we'd like to create a lot more
really good first party courses and we'd
like to create a lot more interactive
curricula we'd love to be able to figure
out a way that we could pay for servers
so that we could actually have Linux
focus challenges get focused challenges
all these things that require like
well.alright systems essentially like
you can only do so much in the browser
just you know for example we're able to
do Python because Mozilla just released
a giant library that's a significant
update from like breath on or some of
these other browser-based Python tools
but we'd really like to be able to
actually have full development
environments on a server that is showing
up on free code camp that you yourself
have your own little mini you know
compartment on the server it costs a lot
of money yeah so yeah if we if we're
able to increase the budget we're gonna
just keep doing what we doing those
three pillars we're gonna keep growing
the number of people on the forum and by
extension in IRL events and we're also
going to just keep creating articles and
videos and we're gonna keep expanding
the curriculum we haven't talked about
that's how the publication your YouTube
channel I mean we're on there
theoretically subscribe yeah click the
bell that's right
youtubers they always it's like
subscribe and the Bell right why did
YouTube do that twice I've never hit the
Bell what's you know actually it's kind
of a double opt-in you subscribe cuz
you're interested what's the Bell give
you it like make notifications I don't
care that much that you know I don't
video like I'll come watch it on my own
terms now yeah that's no one's that
important well that's where the double
opt-in is get it from the from the
creator side yeah I would love to have a
bell for my channel but I don't want to
have your bail for my feed keep your
bell all right keep your bell
well Quincy man it's an amazing journey
it's been it's been fun watching you
over these last five years the numbers
speak for themselves I think the fact
that you're you can educate as such a
efficient rate makes it total sense for
people who are who have you know the
funds and have benefited from free code
camp or know people who have you know
that five bucks seems like it makes a
lot of sense so you know one more time
to pitch to our listeners if if you
appreciate the work they're doing and
you want to help educate the next
generation of coders out there whether
they're young whether they're young or
old or what part of the world they're in
yeah no better way than to do a
recurring donation to free code camp
company says better know better there's
no more efficient way right and the
leverage is amazing yeah yep and yeah
thanks for sitting down with us we
really appreciate you and all the work
you're doing thanks again for having me
back it's been a privilege talking to
you gentlemen thanks Christy same here